hello everyone
welcome to this full course video on
html by simply learn this video will
help you understand all the concepts of
html and provide lots of hands-on
example
so
let's discuss the agenda of this
tutorial
we started discussing what is html in 10
minutes
then we will discuss html classes in ids
and drop down html
after that we will discuss the content
boxes and html image slider
then we will see how i can create the
navigation bar registration form and
html quiz in html after all the learning
will design a fully functional website
using all the concepts that we have
learned we'll end with the web developer
roadmap and how you can achieve your
target of becoming a front-end web
developer
so let's begin
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user
then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the ip
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is
so your browser starts by loading the
main html file and then the css and
javascript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the backend of an
application now secondly we have
the server once you've developed your
website you will have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's ipaddress which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an ip address
we put a domain name over that ip
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is html
html is the most widely used markup
language for developing and structuring
web pages on the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is css then
now css is a simple design language used
for making web pages look more beautiful
and presentable
it can be attached to any html element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is javascript
now javascript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development
it is used for making web pages
interactive and bringing the web pages
to life
so now let's create your first website
now html short for hypertext markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs
div containers tables and more html tags
are nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags
so now let's write a simple html code
that will help you understand the basics
of the language
so for this i'm using the text editor
that is visual studio code you can go
ahead and download this text editor from
their official website so here i've
created a simple dot html file in my vs
code and i've added the initial html
files
now let me explain to you one by one
now doc type is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction
now this indicates the browser that the
document type to be served to the user
is in fact an html document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your html page
next up you have the html tag that is
used to contain all the web pages html
code
right so it contains an opening and
closing tag with contents in between
them
the html tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page followed by the html tag there's
the head tag now this is the first
section of the code that contains all of
the information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
pages title description additional meta
tags and css code so here i've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
html
in 10 minutes
[Music]
all right
you can also add css to the head tag by
using the style tag and change the
display styles of html elements that are
being used
the next section is the body tag now the
body tag contains all the displayable
contents of your web page including
headings paragraphs div containers
tables and more
now the html header tags are used to add
headings to a web page there are several
types of headings available for
developers to add to a web page right so
first up let's have a look at them i'm
going to create a simple h1 heading tag
and the message i'm displaying is
this is
the first heading
all right
after this i'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so i'm gonna add a p tag
and say
this is the paragraph tag
[Music]
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading tag and say this is the
second heading
now you can also add line breaks which
are helpful from time to time if you
want to provide a single line break in
your content you can do so by adding the
br tag
so here let me just add one for
better understanding
now the html div tag defines a division
or a section in an html document that is
used as a container for other html
elements
now these elements can include content
areas sidebars page bars page headers
footers etc
this tag is used to apply styles to html
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the html image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a web page are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so say img
within which i mentioned the source
[Music]
i'm adding the html logo so let me just
mention that here
and then i'm going to provide width for
it and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file
and when you look at the browser
you can see that
the first heading is displayed then your
paragraph tag is displayed followed by
the second heading and then the image
now let me show you how you can add
styles for some of these
headings and paragraph tags so here in
back in my
first heading tag let me just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
and i'm going to change it to career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so i'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when i look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
html tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website in this tutorial
we are going to learn about the classes
and id in the html and how to use them
so
without further ado let's get started
so
what is an html class
an html class attribute is used to
specify a single or multiple class names
for an html element
the class name can be used by css and
javascript to do some tasks for html
elements
you can also use this class in the css
with a specific class with a period
character followed by the name of the
class first selecting elements
so let's jump on to the demo to
understand the classes and id better so
we are on our sublime text editor
let's add the standard boilerplate of
html
we'll give the title as
classes
and id in html
let's start with the basic example
we will see how to define an html class
so inside the body tag
we'll add one h1
and we'll give this
the class name of
head one
will add some text here this
is
the heading one
now you can copy this part because we'll
need it enough for the lines
so for the h2
this will be the heading 2
for h3
this will be heading 3
and let's add one more h4
this is the heading 4.
so as you can see we have used the same
class name in all our h1 h2 h3 and h4
so if you save the file and
go to the page and refresh
you'll see the headings are there on the
page this is the heading 1 heading 2
heading 3 and heading 4
now let's learn how we can use this
class name for our styling purpose
so we'll open the style tag here
and you will mention the
class name by
period followed by the class name so
head 1
open the parenthesis
and let's set the color to
like cn
and we'll set the font family to
set to it cursive
keep the background color to
black
okay so you can see we have mentioned
the class name dot head head one for our
styling purposes and we have given the
color point family and background color
for it so just save the file and go back
refresh
now you can see we have designed this h1
h2 h3 and h4 using our class tag
now let's use another example with a
different class name
so
here only will make the changes let's
name this class as h2 this h3 and let it
be h4
now you can style them separately for
the head too
we can set the color
to say light
pink and we can set the font background
color to
red
okay
now
similarly for the h3
dot
head 3
set the color to
[Music]
i don't know what color this is let's
say fujisa
and set the background color
to
let's say blue
okay save the file and go back to the
page
now you can see we have designed our h1
h2 h3 and h4 using the different class
name
this is the example of using the
multiple classes on the same code
now one thing you should note that these
class name must be separated by the
space
there are a few points you should know
while working with the class
so the first one will be the class
attribute can be used on any html
element
like any html element can have a class
name the second point will be the class
name is the case sensitive
head one
and
if we change here to say
we'll keep this h as kept capital so
this will be wrong the style won't be
implemented on the page now if you
refresh
you can see the style is not implemented
so the class names are case sensitive
let's change this back
refresh and now you can see our design
is back
so this was all about html classes
now let's move on to the id attribute
so the html id attribute is used to
specify the unique id for an element of
the html document
it allocates the unique identifier which
is used by the css and the javascript
for performing certain tasks
in cascading stylesheet that is css we
mention an element with a specific id by
using the hash symbol followed by the id
so let's work on an example to
understand this better
so we'll use the same previous example
we'll mention the h1 and this time we'll
use the id
so id and we'll name it as head one
this is the first heading
or h2 also
will mention the id name as head one
only
head one
this is the
second heading
now to style the heading we'll go back
here
we'll open the style tag
and we'll use the hash number to mention
the id so hash
head one open the parenthesis
we'll set the color to
light green
we'll set the font family to cursive
and we'll set the background color
to black
okay
now save the file and go back and
refresh
so you can see this works in a similar
manner to the class apart from it that
we use the hash symbol to mention the id
name
so
now let's change the example and use the
different id names for different edge
ones
so this can be h1
this can be h2
let's add one more
we'll name it as id
head 3
okay
so
we'll style the
head
too we'll set the color to red
for head tree
we'll set the color to
yellow
let's use green yellow okay
save the file go back
and refresh
now you can see we have the different
style for different ids
so in this way you can use the different
ids
to design your html page in this
tutorial we are going to learn how you
can create a drop down in your nav bars
using just html and css so we are on our
sublime text later i have the dot html
and dot css file ready
so let's start by adding the standard
boiler plate
let's give it a title
link your css file to the html file
now inside the body i'll add the ul's
we have added this hash so that when you
click on this home button it won't
redirect you to anywhere
so just save the file
and we'll go back to our page
so you can see we have this home here
okay so let's add some
more so just copy paste this
and we'll name this section about
now inside this about i'll require some
sub menus
so inside this i'll open another ul tag
we'll add sections such as team
clients
career and legacy
and we'll close the li tag here
okay now save the file and go back here
and refresh
now we'll add some more
so
here
we'll add the li for contact
okay so inside this contact i'll add the
submenus
so
you will
and i'll
copy this code and i'll edit it here
okay so inside the contacts i'll need
email
phone
let's hit
twitter
and this will be my linkedin
okay
now we'll add some more sections
we'll name the services
and this one will be my news
okay
so this looks fine
a little bit of alignment
yeah
so you can see
we have this home about contact services
and news and inside this we have the sub
menus
okay we forget to
add here
hash inside these specifics
mention hash
everywhere
okay save the file
go back and refresh
okay so you can see we have this html
ready
now let's go back to the css and design
these
drop downs
so first inside our html
select the body tag
we'll add one background image so just
the background looks
more
attractive
so i have an image file saved so i'll
jpg so save
go back
and refresh
yeah you can see we have this black
thing uh we'll shrink this image
so we'll keep the background size to
cover
and we'll keep the font family to arial
yeah okay
so for the ul tag
we'll keep the margin to zero
we'll keep the padding to zero as well
and we'll set the list style to none
okay now
we'll design the uli part
so we'll keep the float to left
width will set to 200 pixels
we'll set the height to say 40 pixels
um we keep the background color
do something darker say
dark blue
dark grey okay
keep the opacity to 0.9
line height 40 pixels
keep the text aligned
to center
and font size to
20 pixels
save the file go back and refresh
okay you see we have the background
image in the place we have this snap bar
in the place
and all the drop downs are here
okay
now it's time to design you will
l i and a
so for this we'll keep the text
decoration to none
color let's keep white
and we'll set the display to block
save the file and go back
now we'll add the whole effects for this
drop downs okay
so ul
ally
a dot forward
we'll keep the background color
for the hover
to say
anything you can circulate select light
salami
save
let's see how it looks on the page
refresh
yeah it's look good
now the final part of this requires this
to shrink inside just when you hover
over this so the drop downs will appear
okay
so we'll set this ulli
li 2
display none
and we'll add the over effect over like
so that when we hover the drop down
appears
save
go back and refresh
now you can see all the dropdowns are
inside this
when you hover over it and the drop
downs appear
okay
so this is all about the drop downs menu
in html i saw that we can create the
beautiful drop downs just by using the
html and css nothing fancy
in this video we are going to create the
content boxes which are used in web
pages for various purposes
so let's see an example of what we are
going to create so in this video we are
going to create something
like this this is the content box with
the icon and the description of the
content box
icons here used is from the font
awesome cdn
so let's start creating
so i have my two files open which is
html and css
let's add the standard boiler plate
we'll add the content
boxes in
html
as the title
let's link our css file
now inside the body
let's add a div class container
inside the disk class container i'll
create another div
box will require three such boxes so
we'll copy this this three times
on the style sheet
let's set the margin
to 0
and padding also to 0.
we'll set the font
family to
spam serif
now
for the container
class
we'll set the position to relative
we'll set the width to 1200 pixels
which is the whole width of the content
box
we'll set the height
to 300 pixels
and we'll set the margin
to
240 pixels and auto
for the boxes inside the container
will add the position
relative
and will set the width to
let me explain what this is
this css type function is used to
perform a calculation to be used as a
property value
this is specifically used for the width
of the div classes
it requires a mathematical expression
the result will be used as a value
so we'll be using lot of this calc
function here in this code
we will set the height to
300 pixels minus 30 pixels
one property of calc function is that it
takes single expression as its parameter
the expression can be any simple
expression combining the following
operators
plus
that is addition minus that is
subtraction multiplication and division
we will set the background
to hash 0 0 0
we'll set it to float left
and we'll specify the margin to 15
pixels
and we'll set the box sizing to border
box
overflow will be hidden
and border
radius
let's set it to 10 pixels say
just save the file and let's
go back to the page to see how it
currently looks
so you can see our boxes are in the
proper places we have the background
black with the proper margin between
them
okay so we have the structure
let's
code more
now we need the icon
for that
we will require
a icon from the font awesome
cdn so we'll add the font awesome cdm to
our page
so we will search
quantosim
cdn 4.7.0
we are using the older version because
it is more stable
so go to this font awesome
libraries
here select the version and copy the
link tag
go back to the page and add it here
delete this integrity part
now
here inside this class box
add one div which will be named class
icon
and inside here we'll add the link of
the icon so search here
font or some icon 4.7
go to the first one
here you can search the any icon you
want let me search for
say
information
so i'll go to the information
and i'll copy this
go back to the code and add it here
now inside this i'll create another div
which will be for use for content
so we'll name it class content
and inside this i'll add one h3
info
and inside it
i'll add some
text
copy this much from here
to there
and delete this whole part
and put it inside
p tag
so inside the p tag
add them
yeah
so
let's go back to the file and see how it
looks right now
okay so you cannot see the icon here
because it is black let's try to change
the color here
so that you can see the icon
so let's set it to ff0
okay so you can see i have the icon in
place this is and this is the text that
we have added to this content box
now let's style this content box first
set it back to 000
now
container dot box
dot icon
we'll set the position to absolute
set the top
to zero
left to zero
and we'll set the width to 100
we'll set the height also to 100
background will be hash f00
and we'll set the transition
to 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the z index as one so
that the icon will be visible
okay
refresh
yeah you can see the icon here
okay
now let's add the over effect on that
so container
dot
box dot
over
icon
we'll set the
top to 20 pixels
calculate the left two
50 percent minus 40 pixels
with
80 pixels
i keep it 280 pixels as well
and let's set the border radius
to 50
okay so now that we have or
repeat
so now that we have added the hover
effect let's save and go back to the
page
now let's
design the icon so container dot
box dot icon
dot fa
also set the position to absolute
top will be 50 percent
left 50 percent
transform let's translate it to
minus 50
minus 50
and give the font size to
[Music]
80 pixels
transition 0.5 seconds
and we'll set the color to
save the file and let's go back to the
page
yeah
so you can see our icon has now
bigger size and with the hover effect it
shrinks for text to visible
now we need to add the hover effect to
the icon so that the font size increases
for that we'll add container
box dot over
we keep the font size too
40 pixels
okay
now it's time to design the content
inside the container box so we'll set
container
dot box
dot content
all the positions are absolute
we'll set the top 200
so that when the icon shrinks the whole
text will visible to the text box
we will set the height
2 will calculate it
100
minus 100 pixels
text align center
keep the padding 20 pixels
for proper spacing
box sizing as border box
transition to 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the opacity
to zero
okay save the file and let's go back
yeah
and you can see the icons are in the
center of the shrinking circle
now let's add the hover effect
now when you set the opacity to one
another text
okay we are not
designed yet h3np so let's start
designing it
so container
dot box
content h3
in pixels
keep the padding to zero
color
and let's keep the font size to 24
pixels
now you will see the text will be
visible inside the box
so
yeah refresh can see this is the heading
of our
like this content box info
now similarly let's style the paragraph
tag
so container
dot box
content
p
margin will be zero
padding will be also zero
and color will be fff as usual
okay
yeah we are almost there
now we will design these two boxes
with some spacing and effects over here
now
inside this
delete them will copy paste the above
code here
so copy from here dip class container
we'll change the icon classes here
so for this let's keep search as
a rch
instead of copying the class by going
back to the font cd we can directly add
the class search here if you know the
name of the class
and here we can add
location
so the class name for location is map
marker
save the file
and let's go back
yeah now you can see
these things are here
with the good content box when you hover
over this box the
this whole thing shrinks and you can see
the text visible
now add we'll add some styles we'll
change the color and we'll add one
background here so that when the shrinks
the background color of the black
changes
okay
so we'll go back to our code
so to change the color of the box
we'll have here dot container
dot
box
and we'll use the nth child property and
child
one
because the first box
dot icon
so we will keep its background to
think
okay
and dot container
box and child
one
its color will be when it shrinks
let's keep it to orange
yeah
so save the file
go back
and refresh
okay so you can see we have the icons in
places and when you go
click on here so the hover effect
shrinks this and this is the pink in
color we have the background orange with
some text here
you can see
smooth
transitions
so
this is all for the content boxes in
html you can use different icons here
using this font at awesome icon there
are several icons here you can use any
of them
and just make sure that the padding and
the text are aligned in the proper
places in this video we learn how you
can create a beautiful html slider by
using just html and css a little bit of
javascript
our image slider moves something like
this
we have the background image and this
images that i have taken
for example purpose we have these radio
buttons and we click on the radio
buttons
we can go through our images one by one
also the images will change
automatically after sometimes as you can
see
so let's see how we can create this
image slider
so here in the desktop i have created
one file where i have the required
images
and html and css file
so first in the experiment style let's
add our radio buttons
so we'll create one div
and email to disk class slider
and start this day i'll create another
which will be named as bim class slice
inside this big cache slides will add
the radio buttons
so input
the input type will be radio
and let's give this name
radio button
and we'll tag them with id radio one
so as you can see
we need four buttons here so we'll add
four radio buttons here
so just copy paste this four times
here choose the id to radio 2 radio 3
and radio 4 so we can distance between
our four radio buttons
so after the creating the video buttons
we'll add our required images so we'll
create android div and limit class
slide first
inside
i'll create an image tag
and specify the path of the image
in a similar way we create a
four div tags for four images
so just
will do simply
another with class name
slide
inside this image
2.jpg
so just save the file and let's recheck
our code
we have the review buttons we have the
images so let's just go back to our file
and see how it looks
so if we refresh
we see we have the four radio buttons
here and some distorted images
so let's just fix this images in the css
so inside of css style
we'll add the body
and we'll set the margin to 0 pixels
padding to zero
we'll set the height to say under
vertical height
we'll set the display to flip
uh we'll justify the content to center
we'll set the align items to center
and we'll set the background to black
so just
refresh this file
so we still need to fix these images
so just
set the slider width to
800 five
okay this there's an error we'll say
this bit not reduced
we set the height
to 500 pixels
then set the border radius
to 10 pixels
and overflow will keep as hidden
for the slice part
we'll set the width to 500
height to 500 pixels
and display it to select
so let's save the file and see how it
looks on the page
so yeah you can see the images now in a
proper size you have to click this video
button we have the background black
so let's fix this hints
so for the
input
okay before starting this let's add some
more html content here
so after adding the image we have to
create the automatic navigation button
and the manual navigation button
so after this
add another div
the class name
navigation
auto let's see
and inside this navigation auto will add
div
truss
auto button one
we need the full button so we'll copy it
four times
and this will be
my button 2
this is the button 3 and this will be
button
outside this
will create another div
just go for the manual navigation button
so we'll name this
navigation
make sure it's spelled right navi
navigation
manual
and inside this
we'll add our radio button usually
manually
we'll name it class
manual button
we need the core button so we'll copy it
four times
change the label to radio 2
radio 3 and radio 4
so i think
this will work enough so here we have
the navigation
okay we have a spell mistake here
class
and navigation kind of invested classes
so let's recheck our code
it's a good platform to check your code
so that you don't encounter any error so
okay we have a different slider here
and inside the zip close adder we have
the four radio button dd1234
we have added all images
inside the div tags with the name slide
okay
we have created a navigation auto
the four buttons and navigation manual
buttons okay
so let's save the file and go back and
refresh it and see how it looks
okay
we have to add some css here
so inside the slides
input
before
foreign
now we'll
add this type of image
we'll set the width to 800 pixels
and we'll set the height to say 500
pixels
okay
let's save the file and let's go back to
see how it looks right now
okay so you can see the images are
properly aligned here
we have to style our radio buttons for
here so let's go back to our css
navigation
so just add here comment manual slide
navigation
so we'll add the first
class navigation manual
will set the position to absolute
then set the width to 800 pixels
will not have the height here we'll set
the margin
so the margin top will be
minus 40 pixels
this we will keep it as left
and the justify content
will be sent out
so let's go and
go back to the page to see how it looks
right now
okay the images are in the center you
can see
now we cannot see the regular buttons
just as now we have to add some color to
it so that the radio buttons will be
visible
so go back to the css
3
pixels solid and red
you can take any color you want
we'll set the padding to five pixels
uh we'll set the border radius
to
say nine pixels
we set the processor to point pointer so
that when
buttons the cursor will look as a
pointer
and we'll set the transition to one
seconds
save
go back and refresh
so now you can see the buttons are here
not properly spaced but yeah they're
here
so let's add the spacing and everything
else
so we will set the manual button
we'll set the margin
right to 40 pixels
and it's time to add the whole effect so
for the manual
button
will be um save
background
the color
blue
so just save the file and go back and
refresh
yeah so you can see our manual buttons
are in place
when you hover over it you can see the
blue effect and when you click
nothing happens right now because we
don't have any javascript in response to
this later button
we'll add them in the end
first let's design these buttons so this
was for the manual button
now we'll add one code which will be
used when you want to save the reader
button by default
so let's understand how those video
buttons work in this file so the radio
version is used where two or more
options are identified which are
mutually exclusive and the user has to
do exactly one choice
in other words click on a non-selected
reader button will erase any other
button that is selected on the list
previously
derivatives include lower cognitive
layers as they permanently keep all the
options visible such that users can
easily analyze them
radio buttons are also simple to use for
users who have difficulty making
effective mass movements
so we'll add hash radio
dot check
so the sign that we have added here is
more signaling combinator
it combines two sequence of simple
selectors having the same parent and the
second must come immediately after the
first
so
we'll add dot first
and for this we'll set the margin left
to zero
okay so this will be radio one
the label that we're adding in our
manual buttons
we'll need four such
buttons so we'll copy this four times
one two three and four
this will be my for radio button two
and we'll set the margin left here to
minus twenty pixels
for radio button three
and for the last button
we'll set it to minus 60 pixels
so all this code is for the manual
navigation button
now let's design for automatic
navigation button
so
we'll open dot navigation
set the position to absolute
then set the display to flat
we'll set the width
to 800 pixels
let's just define the content of the
center
so i'll add the style to navigation auto
so
navigation content
then set the border
to same water that we have used here
let me shape it solid red
make sure you keep the sequences solid
and same in both the navigation auto and
navigation manual because if you change
the color here you will see the two
manual buttons there so
for
this example let's change this to green
so when you save and go back
and refresh
yeah
but you can see the two buttons there
this is a green and this is red so if
there are two colors the
both the buttons will overlap will not
feel good
so we'll just keep it here red
we'll set the padding to five pixels
we'll set the border radius to 9 pixels
and we'll set the transition to 1
seconds
now same code as here which i've added
for
checking out the radio buttons
so we'll just copy this whole code
and paste it here
i'll have to tweak some
things here
so the class was navigation dot auto
so we'll add here
navigation
dot
auto button one
we'll filter some background
so we'll delete this code
um
background let's say
any color
pink
so
copy this code ctrl c
delete this whole thing
and just change the radio button there
this will be radio button
this will be three
and this will be phone
now we have all the designing in place
now we have already designing this let's
go back to the code and refresh
so now you'll see everything is in place
the background is black the images is
perfectly aligned we have this button so
let's click
so when you click you see the images
slides this is the photo match
third
second
and first so
your beautiful image slider is ready all
right now is left is to add the
javascript code to this image slider to
function in automatic manner
so now we'll go back to this html5
and below this dev tag
will open one script tag
and inside the script tag
we create one
variable named counter
set it to one
open we create one function set interval
so
so
so what this part specifically does is
we have created one
variable named counter and it would
check against the id that we have
created in radio then the radio button
is
checked and it encounters
the counter will be plus plus that
control increase by one
so
after the counter has reached the floor
so it will get back to the starting
point that is one
so
the whole point of this code is to
make the images slide in in a loop
so just save
and go back
now when you refresh
you will see the images will move after
sometimes
specifically two seconds
now when the images become the last
stage it goes back to the first
you can also change it by clicking here
manually when we talk about achievement
based development so in html based
development navigation is very important
where you have multiple pages attached
to so that when you click on this page
or click on any hyperlink it will take
you to the new page now so that you can
move back and forth so this navigation
is very essential part of any web
development so that you can offer the
navigation so this
simple application of html they would
like to start from scratch so let's go
and create a new folder now and give the
name called navigation
and inside this navigation we want to
create some new pages
so
here i'm going to create index
dot html
the css name would be
app.css and along with this we would
like to also create some new folder
inside this i'll keep all the navigation
files inside this so i can save pages
inside this pages let me have total
number of three pages with me one is
called about
dot html
then we create
contact
dot html
then we create one more that is called
services.html
dot html
so these three links we will create it
one by one but first let's start with
the index.html
so what's there in my index.html file
so
first thing i would like to start with
my same html syntax
here
well
this is my basic construct
so i will start with my
link real from here so that i can have
my style check with me link really cool
to style sheet href equal to
see it says though i have not written
anything but i just left it as a blank
in my body tag i would start with the
navigation so html5
brought you some new tags known as call
which is once again
won't change anything drastically in
your browser however they are called
semantics which will help you for the
seo that stand for search engine
optimization so i'll start with my nav
inside my nav i will start with my div
div
i'll say navigation bar so but before
that i say
class equal to
heading
there's my div tag
and inside my tip tag i want to bring my
heading so i say h4
and i said
navigation bar
and after the div tag i will start with
my url tag which is the unordered list
inside my
unordered list i can set li that stand
for list items
and i can offer log menu links inside
this so you will i just offer the class
equal to
nav hyphen
links
and inside this my li tag i say
a which is the anchor tag
so
a link href equal to
now here i offer
the name i say index
dot html and
that's it and this will be by default
active so we say
class equal to
active
a
class equal to it
active and http equal to index.html5 and
here we offer home
for home page
i'll copy this line
and paste it for other three urls
so
here
the
active won't be there
instead we say hf equal to
the location called
pages under this pages
we say about
about.html and here we say about
okay copy this
paste it
and a part of this about we always say
services.html
and here we say
services
inside this your
contact
contact
okay
and once the nav tag is over
i will offer the tip
just give the name body hyphen
text
i just say
h1 tag inside this
and this is the home page
that's it so that's my home page which
is ready with me
and along with this whichever the other
pages are also available
those pages i also want to use
so first of all let me check how this
page looks like it
well it looks like a pretty basic page
so once this page is ready
what i will do is
here
i copy the content
and paste it here and above and let's
see what's there in my above see few
things will change
number one here
this app.css
now here we have to just use
dot dot
there's an app.css for me
so
we have to offer some title too so after
this linkarion
the offer
title this title i can say
about
okay
so rest everything is fine
so h4 navigation bar nav links here
i have to offer the links for my base
html page
so
when i talk about index.html file
okay it won't come so
index.html5
so i won't say it is an active anymore
just remove this line
class equal to it's just a
normal h
but about would be active in this case
so
a
class equal to
active edge of this
services
contact
is as usual saying but i would not be
having any
pages anymore
because we are in the same location
that's why
and here i say this is a
about this is about page
about page
so
that's it
i'll go back and check
if it all fine
home is active right now
about you can see it as an about page
right now
the word page is just appear as it is
saying
contents are more or less looks like and
same that is why you are able to see
now just like that
just go back and copy the others
now here
up css navigation bar
active
it doesn't contact so i'll make contact
as an actor
so text html file remains same this is
contact page
so
that's how it is
and we will say about my other
properties which is my
services
copy sorry
copy this contact
and here
i'll be activating my
service in this case
so
class equal to active i remove it from
here
make it available here this is a
surface page navigation index page is
about active yeah all looks good heading
about over here i changed
service
there's a change to
contact so looks fine
let's see
okay service contact
about
so for about we need to check where we
need to go
so we have got pages
about html pages also there
so
all there so we would like to see
how the about page will be activated
here so index.html file also contains an
about
so here
when i
refresh
well
[Music]
we will call
index.html page
talk about about
there is another page now
services
so like this
it is happening for you
okay so
that's how exactly my thing is
so we're all good and
services contact
on all good
well my page is now ready and going
forward we would like to beautify my
pages by offering the css well let's get
started with our css file
so in my css file i will start with my
common properties
which is margin
i'm saying 0
pixel
followed by padding
i'm making a zero pixel again
again we want box sizing
this is a border
iphone box
okay
well going forward this is my standard
settings for all different type of
properties now i want the other
properties to be get introduced that is
called box body text dot
body
hyphen
text
inside this body text i said display
flex
now when i see where the body text is
available go to my text.html file
body text is available here dev class
so here in my css file i can say body
text display flicks
i say font family
font family i can give anything
it is given called mod
share it
these two
we are offering it
later on align items
in our item center
followed by justify content
and making a center
then margin top
250 pixels
these are the properties are there
followed by
okay first let's check what is an effect
here
see
it looks better now
now we would like to go ahead with the
nav
i already have this nerve with me
now
display
flex then justify content
space around
followed by
align item
align items i want to make center
and then we want to say min height
so
we say min
hyphen
okay so min height we are giving 8vh
followed by background color
just set the
same color
and
same font family i just copy this form
timely and make it available here
well let's check
there we go so navbar looks awesome but
i still feel the links needs to be
justified we want to make it even more
better but before that i offer the
nav links so here
i say
nav links so dot name
hyphen lens
this nav links will have display
flex
display
flex
and then justify content
that i want to make it space around
again
followed by width
so
[Music]
width
so width would be 30 percent
perfect and now
nav link li dot
nav links
li
this
list style
none
let's see how it is changing
there we go that it looks really nice
so nav links are ready and
i want to make it a heading heading
i want to make it more organized so
let's see about a heading
so here i say dot
heading
and inside this heading i say color
which is white
followed by text
transform
text text transform upper case
followed by letter spacing
this letter spacing will be 5 pixels
and followed by large font size
and this font size is just 20 pixels
that's it and let's see what is
differentiated
here awesome so this navigation bar is
now looking great
and it is giving me all the basic
operation whichever we have expected now
this nav links whichever we have created
okay they are working fine but i just
want to make it even more beautiful
and how i can make it more beautiful to
make it i would like to go ahead with
the nav links again
dot
nav links
of type anchor tag
now i would like to activate my anchor
tag by making it color
white okay followed by text decoration
text decoration
and followed by letter spacing
let us pressing 3 pixels
then
font fit
font weight bolt
and font size
14 pixels
and padding
14 pixels
and 16 pixels
both options that's it
and uh
followed by we want to use the nav links
when i will hover it so the color should
change so we are saying dot
nav links
and here with li
followed by a dot
active when the anchor tag is active
then in that case i want to change the
background color
to
lights light see green i can say
lights
so
[Music]
we have this option called light c green
this one right that looks beautiful
and followed by same
i copy this
and this active
so nav links like dot active
background color we are using but if it
is not active then in that case what you
will use
so
i can just change the small thing
here
i have changed this color
uh
now let me try to copy this first
i tell you about what i want
to copy this and paste it as usual here
what i see is when it is an active
okay when it is an active i will change
the color to
i think the spelling is wrong
active it should be
active
background color i want to change it to
green so for that we're just using the
color
hash
this is a green color
where it is are active and when this is
not active
so we can just say a colon
active
which is used now now li colon active or
we can say equal over
equal
over
a
colon
over and here we say colon
not
active
that's it
let's see how it works
awesome this looks beautiful home home
is active right now they say it is on a
home page
i can see it is an about page
it is service page it is a contact now
you can see it looks even more
awesome in this html piece hands-on we
are expecting that all of you are aware
about the basic concept of html as well
as the css so this
kind of learning is going to help you to
understand like how html and css can
connect together while offering you a
mini application the first application
on this track we're gonna offer you that
is related to your html registration
page okay so
as you know for this particular
registration development application i
would like to use the visual studio code
which is one of the very very popular
tool provided by microsoft so this tool
will be using it for our mini
application development so let's get
started with this
so step number one let me go back and
create a new folder now i'm going to
create a new folder name called
registration
and inside this i would require two
files number one it's called index dot
html
another one that is called
css we can say
f
app.css
so in index.html file
we want
some standard development so i want to
start with my html tag
so
i already have this html base autofill
code provided by your visual studio code
so there are plugins are available
inside this so that you can
automatically create the basic
structure for this html which you can
have the html tag head tag
as well as the body tag and from this
point onwards we will start developing
our code now so
i want to develop a registration page so
in this registration page i will start
from my
form tag now so inside this form it is
saying like form action to something i
really do not have any backend so i just
leave it as a blank and here i will
start with my h1 tag where i want to say
register
after this register i want to offer the
paragraph tag
where i can say please
fill
in this
form
to
register with us
register
with us
okay
now after that i would like to start
with horizontal row
so hr
so
starting with my horizontal row
and pause this because see we would like
to organize our application and now
level
in this level for
i just wanted to give the name called fm
it's just the name
and after this fn stands for the first
name
and within this level i would like to
use the b tag which is a i would say the
bold
here i will pass first name
bold tag is closed it's a label
inside this label i would like to use
input tag
here i will call input type equal to
text
and offer a few other details also like
i say
a placeholder placeholder will offer you
what to be filled i'm saying first name
that is
the placeholder value after this name
equal to
fn that is a stand for first name
after that id
id is option
but if you want to pass we will use this
id fn
id equal to fn
and
required
because i want this field cannot be
blank
so this is my
first text box where i have this
first name with me
like that i will go ahead and talk about
my
next property or password and for
password also i would like to have the
similar details with me
so this level i'll copy
and paste it
below and this is for
your password so we're giving the name
called psw
here we are saying password
and uh input type into text so here i
will change input applicable to password
because password field
details would not be visible to you
please
here we say
placeholder i can say enter
password
name equal to
you can give psw
id equal to we can give same psw
so
we have a password in a similar line we
would like to offer the confirm password
fields too
i will copy this line
and paste it again
and here we can say confirm password
you can say cpsw
again password enter
confirm password cpsw
and
cpsw now it's over
after this we want to make it as a
horizontal row
closed
and once it is run then we'd like to
have the button with this
so here is the button we can say
register
and here in my button
i would like to offer the type equal to
submit
are we going to
submit
so that's it so this is
the simplest form i have it
now i would like to see how it really
looks like it
so from here i would like to open it
revealing finder
let's open this
well it looks like that
fine so this is what my formless form is
ready and now we would like to go back
and start developing my css in which i
would beautify my form to offer some
more details of this
well friends as we know the html page is
ready it's time to go back and start
developing a css to beautify my html so
inside the css i would like to start
with the tag which is a call body
and
inside this body tag i can offer some
basic setups but
i just want to keep the basic background
color now which is called
background hyphen color
i can just give the name called t here
that's a background color let's the rest
of the things i can just leave it as it
is now for all the other properties i
can say box sizing
border iphone box
after that
dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits
now first thing you need to understand
which other places i will be using the
container so you see here in my
index.html file
when we talk about form actions and all
okay we say h1 register we haven't used
any container right now so let's get
added the container
div
class equal to
container
okay and this particular div tag will
get closed only at the last
so
this tip tag
will close at the last
here
so i want to make
the look and feel for this complete
container
in much more better way so here in my
container we want to say
margin
auto press enter here
margin
auto
now width
50
then adding
16 pixel
followed by background color
which we want white
then box shadow
this box shadow we want to give some all
four origins 20 pixels
continuation to same 20 pixel
and zero pixel
and which color we want so i just say
rgba
in this rgb you just give the value
called zero
again
zero
again 0
and
the value which you want to give to this
alpha because it
is always between
0 to 1 we are saying zero point seven
that is an opacity
well four properties is given now let's
see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a css
in my html so let's add the css so
inside my
browser html
now inside my head
we add link
link rl equal to style sheet href equal
to
laptop css
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now
so this is your container okay which you
can see it is having some shadow i would
like to organize this all set up text
boxes in much more better way
so
after this
we want to offer the other
properties to liken for my input
go back to my css
so after this container we want input
input again
time equal to
text
now
also
to
input
type
equal to
password
here we offer few things number one
width
which is 100
after
sorry
then padding
once again 15 pixels
then margin
you're offering 5 pixels
0
22 pixel
0
followed by display
display i will say
inline block
inline block
followed by border do you want any
border
so i say null
border none and background
we can offer the color so we can say
white smoke
that's it let's see in my html
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized
so this is
your form but i want to make it even
more better now because i want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the beautification needs to be
added more
here
we want to offer the same input type
text input type password i copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
focus this has to be your focus
focus and here also
on focus
now background color
we want to change to anything but for
typing we can just give
same
and
outline
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button
so
here we say dot
i do not have that class for register
button so i have to create this class
inside my
button
register btn
i would like to offer the properties for
those like background color
t
followed by color
which is
white
then padding
we offer 16 pixel
then border
then cursor
i think it is better to have pointer
only
then width
100
solve by margin
this auto
then opacity
then i say 0.8
fine so this is for my registration
button
let's see
wow this looks better now
so this is a full size button
so this is for my button
and i want the moment i take my cursor
on button
the color should change or it should
look like an hover
copy this
over
and here we say opacity
which is with the value for 1
that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this you see how the
conditions are working when i press on
register you see the messages
please filter field blank and it is
changing
the
when we talk about the situation
called focus so in this it works like
that when i give the name
you see now how the background color is
changing now so it is little bit more
grayish color so this time we're going
to develop another very interesting
example
using this html
javascript and css together and that is
called working with a quiz application
so one of the very very interesting
projects will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all i'm going
to give the name called
html
quiz
now i'm going to create a three files
inside this number one i'm going to say
index.html
index.html
then i need another file that is called
app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
dot js
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first
so we'll go to the html and see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards div tag
so within my tab tag
we would like to create
another div tag
okay
so the first top level class
to this particular tip
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so we see
the
class equal to container
now we have got another tab tag inside
this we will set them
id
equal to question hyphen container
question hyphen
container so that is the name or id of
this tab
and we say class
equal to hide
now within this step tag
we would like to offer some details
but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tip tag here
and this dev id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes we are just creating
it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this div tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer a few buttons
now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer one
answer one
so that i can have this button class
copy it three more times
and now we can change
the names to
two
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us
dev tag is getting closed here another
tube tag is getting closed here
and now here
before the last step tag is getting
close we would like to create another
div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's another tip tag so under this div
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start iphone btn
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
btn
space
btm
and we say start here
now just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so
rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next iphone button
next hyphen button btn and we will give
additional property called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s capital
and
next
two buttons we have created
after this div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
tab tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span
and here we will say span
id equal to
right hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so
after that the div tag is getting closed
and
that's it
and it last
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this drive tag i would like to close
even before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip type which is closed
at the end
and here we want to include the script
tag
a script
src equal to
script.js
that's it our html page is almost ready
let's review
and
yes i can see
some standard buttons has been created
now we would like to look make gifs a
better look and feel to this kind of
button cell
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things here
we're providing a route
and with this route some basic settings
we are offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
q
hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral
the value is giving a score
200 after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen
hue
again
hyphen rom
this value we're giving us
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
145
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hyphen hue
this we are making with the variable
hyphen iphone you
neutral the one which we have already
declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we are giving zero
next property is margin
module will also remain 0
after that display
none
after that not display i would say
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we are providing width almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contents i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
and this will we would like to use this
var
again this in this world we are using
hyphen hyphen view
and followed by
100
comma
20
these things and this is style we
wouldn't we would like to use in my
index.html page
so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
refine the styles we always use
link
link
css
so the value is automatically style.css
but we would like to change to app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body dot
correct
body dot correct
we're providing
queue
var
and here you would like to offer
iphone iphone draw
and also sorry not wrong just work
correct
and
we can use
body
dot wrong
so same thing i'd like to copy
so rather than saying correct
we're using
rock
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
container inside my container i would
like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80
now going forward background color
background color we are offering white
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box shadow becomes a 0
0
10 pixels
2
pixels so this is we have applied for
the container and container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now
we would like to offer the buttons
here in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so
dot
btn hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file
so we have a call button grid this
button grid we would like to start from
here
beating grid beaten grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying 2
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then zero
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot btn
followed by the details so
i
will be using neutral
but
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and
hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
were
hyphen i want you
followed by
100
30
okay so these are the values for
border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so
in background color we will just use hsl
rather than this
so hyphen hue
100
and 50
okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding
just
5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white
for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button hover
dot
btn dot or
whole
and for this performer
you want to say border color
this watercolor you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well
so
this is how my
initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use
dot
start
hyphen btn
and also for
dot
next hyphen beta
common look and feel for both
font size
one
dot five
already
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give bold
followed by padding
this padding is be like 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls reset display
flex
followed by justify contents
just justify content services center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and
last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display
none it let's check this out
well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start directly the
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is
well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const
and here we will say
start
button
equal to
document dot
get element by id and here it will give
the name called
start
hyphen vtn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like
here
another one
here we change the name
and give the name called
question
container element
container
element
question container element documentation
by id
here we give the name called question
hyphen container
hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called question element
question
element documented good element by id
here will be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers
or i can say
answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shovel question because we
want every time the questions to be get
shuffled
shuffled questions
shuffle questions
current question
index
shuffle quotients and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
const
questions
equal to
eric
first question which i would like to
create it here is called question
now here we will say
javascript framework
so which of these
is it
which one of these i would say which one
of these is a
javascript framework
this is my question now
okay so i would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i see text
first will be python
python
okay
python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so
i can say true
last i'm keeping its core
false as usual
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create a few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers so i just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who's the prime minister of india
so we can have two
answers available
okay
talk about render mode value is called
work true
second we're gonna give the name call
this value is called false
so taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 x 3
i can have many answers
so i'm just making the first is called 6
which is false seconds 12
like that total we have created
3.
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer
one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be nodes called clear
status class
function
player
status
class it takes some parameter call
element
and here we will say element dot
classlist
dot
remove
element.classlist.remove
correct
and once again i copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
called what
right
and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached there
is only one function attached that's
called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
call
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by we are saying if
correct
then
element dot
class list dot
add
correct
okay
else
use the same option
what will try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use
const
select selected button
selected button equal to e dot
target
number one second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this
set status class function
in this set status class we'll be
passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and
correct
is the second parameter
okay now we're using
array
dot from
and here in this editor form we're using
answers
button element
dot
children
okay
followed by
dot
for each here
we're using
this button
as in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called set status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button
dot
data set
dot
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the main evaluated value
called f
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current question index
plus one
then what
then we are saying
next button
dot
class list
dot
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot class list
dot
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
call if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document dot
get element by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by dot
inner html equal to
quiz
score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
dot
class list
dot
add
height
okay
now
we are using this while option now
answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we'll be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is
something which we wanted to start with
okay well
reset state is already set
now going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function
show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
in a text
equal to
question
dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question dot
answers
dot
for each and here i would like to use
your passing word
answers and parameter
now
here we like to create a button called
const
button equal to
document dot
get sorry document dot create element
i'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you to set the value
equal to
answer
dot
text
then
followed by button dot
class list
dot
add here we are
offering
btn
okay now you're saying
if
the condition is
answered dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
dot
dataset
dot
correct
equal to
answer dot
correct okay
now
the next thing is we are using button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer button element
dot
append child
of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set
next question
next question
here
function
set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state the function we are calling
it and same
show question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is what the sect
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
start
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal to
we have called questions
dot
sort
okay here we say
math dot
random
and
we are passing this value
okay
after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are giving zero right
now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
class list
dot
remove
height
okay
and then
we're calling
set next question
which is a function we are calling it
and initializing our quiz score
with the value called zero
well start game is
ready
next thing which you to start the cover
button
so here we are saying
start button
dot
add event listener
here
in this
on my click event
i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next we'll be calling
next button
dot
add event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
question index
current question index
plus plus
and set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be
kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so our javascript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with this
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like it
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react
now you can see
is automatically making the rest of them
as a
red and not giving me the next button
now
the prime minister of india i'm saying
great next
and i say
for multiply by 3a12 i said next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask is a flask it says twitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how
dear friends your project is now
completely working
and expected as the way it was designed
for when i once again restart and you
can say start button now it's giving me
four multiply by three that means it is
one second have taken
random question this mini project will
help you to understand how we can align
our content to display to my end user so
not many things are there we have got
css in place we have a html in place and
using some css3 based effects using some
html5 based effects we will be creating
our mini website having some
single html page and
a css and lot of images will help you to
understand in case if i want to develop
a website how to kick start them
okay so let's get started so this is my
folder i've created call web pro and in
a similar folder i'll be creating some
of the files so my first file will be
called styles
dot css
so in this style start series first of
all i need to import some of the fonts
which i will be using it throughout my
development so i'm going to add it
import url
and here i'll be offering the location
by saying
https
songs
dot
google
apis
dot
okay google please dot com slash
css
okay question mark we have to use family
equal to here we can use alure
and with using this pipe symbol we're
using joe's friend
joe's film
plus
sense
so that is the url for me in case if you
want to verify whether this url does
exist or not so what you can do you can
just copy this
and go to your browser
and uh
try to paste this and check if it does
exist yes it does exist that means these
urls are available to us so this is a
url which i'll be using it
for my development after that i'll be
using this asterisk
and providing some of the core features
like a margin
colon 0
followed by other details
okay like i'm saying margin colon 0n
adding once again 0
followed by box sizing
just we're saying bottle box
followed by outline
okay none
okay
and
post this will be offering less style
here we are also saying none
[Music]
after that text decoration
text decoration once again
none
after that font family
font family so we are using this
this option which you are saying called
joe's fill
okay
sends the bar which you have used
comma
you're using one more call signs
hyphen sorry
so this would be a first
set of the style which will be global to
all i'll be using this
well earlier we have given the common
style to all now i'll be giving a style
to my paragraphs
so
here in my paragraph we are trying to
save margin
hyphen
and bottom i want to give all 15 pixels
because i want to develop all the styles
well in advance before i proceed ahead
we are saying font iphone size
yeah font hyphen size that we want to
give it for 14 pixels
followed by line height
line height i'll grab 20 pixels
after that color
color you can give anything
okay so there's one very common color
called light blue
for that there's one value called
five
f
8 e
8
e
and again 8
e
you can see there is called a kind of
light green color which is coming up now
ok which is used now a part of this
paragraph will be using h1 title
okay as shown title and in this h1 title
we are saying margin bottom
margin bottom we are saying 20 pixels
after that color
orange
okay
uh me put semicolon here
along with this font family
this font family will be giving alola
okay along with this we also want to
give curiosity
cursor
okay also text
transform
this text transform i want to use
uppercase
along with this font size
this font size i would like to give 38
pixels
followed by font size
yeah so this font size i want to give is
called 38 pixels
or font size we've already given word
spacing we have to give
this word spacing was given 25 pixels
followed by letter spacing
let us specify 5
pixels so these are the details we have
given for the
h1 title
okay so now we'll be talking about our
buttons
which are the look and feel we have to
go or provide to our button so we are
saying once again
dot btn
okay space a means under my button tag a
what i want so i say
width
180 pixels
once again
yeah
red 180 pixels we're giving height
25 pixels
followed by line height
line height will be giving 35 pixels
followed by border
this border will be 2 pixels
solid
black
okay after that color
color we want to give it i would say red
would be
sufficient enough
followed by display
display i want to give it a score block
followed by margin
margin i want to give 25 pixels
auto and zero
followed by text align
okay
center
so this is for btn a which we have given
along with this btna there are some
other properties are also available i
can dot
main underscore
container
here we would like to provide position
okay
colon
relative
okay
after this position we would like to
also provide the property for navbar
so we are saying navbar
underscore or let's talk about navbar
rest of the stats will be offering it a
little later
with the snare bar we are providing this
width
okay this width will be a hundred
percent
okay this would be a 100
and also we provide height
this height will be 65 pixels
okay provided by position
position we are providing absolute
after 30 second display
display we are providing flex
after that we are saying justify content
justify contents you are saying space
around
after that
we are saying align items
this we are giving
a center
okay along with this we are giving this
logo
of type a
so inside this logo we are saying font
family
this form family we are once again using
the same
the one which you have used earlier
you remember alura and curacao let me
we can use the same
whatever we have used it earlier
so
same condition you can use it here
so we remember earlier what we have used
in my previous program
okay font family so the same font family
i would like to use it here also
okay so logo a but let me check
somewhere down the line
what weight
font family so let me copy the same
and paste here right now
okay so we have a god
family with me
which we have taken it right now to my
existing logo a along with i want to use
for
font size
we would like to use 32 pixels
also color
and as usual i would like to use red
okay
so that is for logo on which we have
basically applied this
a part of this we would like to also use
for navbar
mapper
underscore
item
space uh
and here we would like to provide margin
0
and padding
again 0
followed by line style
list style sorry
list
style here using none see that is the
benefit of having this visual studio
code because sometimes when you're going
wrong it immediately
give you the idea of like saying like
hey you're going somewhere wrong that's
what the suggestions were not given to
us
so till here we've added furthermore
we'll be adding few more stars into my
code well
never
tell you what we have seen now followed
by same
dot navbar
okay underscore
items
followed by
lual which we have it and along with
this we would like to go ahead with this
list items also
and in this list items we need
few details first i talk about golf load
so float left for sure then we talk
about curved
width will be 100 pixels
and now we talk about color height
height will be 40 pixels
well
float width height we have talked about
now we talk about background color
background color we can say light salmon
that looks nice and opacity
opacity we can just give con point eight
followed by line height
light height i can give called 40 pixels
okay along with this we also want
texture line
once again
center
okay this is for
these items
now under the same nav bar you may have
some other properties also
okay this is for navbar uli and we can
also have the same property
copy
but along with this li i can also have
this anchor tag we can select multiple
elements together
so here i would like to offer text
transform
you see this text transform
uppercase
followed by color
this color we are saying black
and we are talking about called text
decoration
text decoration we want nothing
along with this i want display
and as usual it will be a block type
okay that was li and within this anchor
tag i also can have a hover
let me copy the
same and with this anchor i can have the
property name called what
cobalt
so what property you are expecting for
this
so here in my hover property i can say
background color
and i can use
tomato
okay
well after this in the same name bar
items
i also want to have
after the anchor tag what should happen
so this conditions i want to utilize
because i want to offer some of the
animations behavior
right over there so what animations i
would like to go ahead that i need to
offer under this navigation items like
so i just copy this
paste it below but this over which we
are talking about we would like to
change from
to
after okay
after
so i'm removing this background color
with this because background color can
be changed to something else
so i can change to white
right
well
let me have few more properties to be
get added
first thing we are trying to secure
position
position will be absolute
okay we want from left side
left i want to give 50 percent space
after this from bottom
i'm saying zero
okay
now i want to talk about transform
you remember to the property available
in css
and here we are saying
translate
x and in say this translate x i say
minus 50
okay and here we are saying after that
scale
x
okay and here we are providing what zero
so that's what the condition we want to
provide it for the transform
and the next thing will be transform
origin
transform origin by say 50
and again
15
after this we would like to talk about
width
width will be 100 percent
okay and we also want this height
height will be two pixels
okay with hundred percent height two
pixels
after that we talk about transition
in this transition we can talk about
transform
okay transform to 50
ms
okay so these are so far the details
which are available with us
which i would like to use it in my code
okay that is for after of this anchor
tag so when you talk about hover you
further want to change the behavior over
there
so in this case i would like to use the
same
condition i just copy that
and here let me say colon
so you can see
ally
space
a equal and over
colon after
so what conditions you want to use it
here so
transform
okay so here
translate x
okay so here is a
minus
50
scale x
1.0
followed by we would like to use again
dot
nav bar
okay underscore item
okay ul
followed by li followed by once again
url
once again li and here in this case we
want to offer display null
display
none
okay
so
that's okay and one more conditions i
would like to take it here is
here when i say ulli li colon hover so i
can say li
colon
over uli so we will say display
block
that's the condition
okay so so far we have written this much
of css we would like to go ahead and try
to implement some of the html behavior
and we'll be back to our css to make
this possible
okay everyone so we have developed a lot
about css it's time for us to move
towards our next
ui that is called the html part okay so
here
i've already kept it just for the kind
information i've just downloaded few of
the
images
okay from the internet just to utilize
into my application
i'm gonna create
the another
file
and give the name called index.html
okay this index.html file let me have
this template with me okay so i have a
got template with me now here
we want to use some of the
awesome css styles for of my usual
development
so within my head tag we would like to
use this link
this is for css so say link real equal
to stylesheet
and href equal to now i'm going to give
the location so this css anyways is
there that's called style we want to say
called styles.css
and one more style i would like to use
in my code
but the location will be somewhere else
i'm saying
https cdnjs
dot
cloudflare
dot com slash
ajax slash
libs slash font
hyphen
awesome
okay that is a well-known style sheet we
are giving the version called 5.15
dot one slash
css slash
all
sorry
on dot
min
dot css so that is the location actually
okay now i want to just check whether
this location does exist or not so i'll
just copy this
paste it in my browser to verify
well yes this
style does exist so
we would like to go ahead and continue
well i would like to give some title in
case if i want so this is a document i
can just get the name called
website
okay just keep this double capital
website development
coming to my body tag
here i just want to give a tip
class equal to
let's give the name called main
underscore
container
okay and also we want to give id
equal to
oh
that is a div tag for that
okay
now along with this i want to give some
other type of div tags to where i want
to use it now here within this div tag i
want to give another div tag
where i want to provide the navbar so
do
equal to navbar
okay and within this nav bar i want to
use another div track
which says
class
equal to
logo
okay
within this div tag we want to provide
double hlf
okay a href equal to
here we want to provide this
hash okay
and this will be provided to
home so this is we have a got dev class
we have a quality of class equal to logo
and under this we are providing this
hashtag and using
simply run
solutions
okay that is the first anchor tag the
div tag is getting closed and we would
like to start
another tube tag and in this div tag we
would like to say
class equal to
navbar
underscore
items
okay
within this div tag we would like to use
this human
and within this ul i would like to use
this li
okay and in this ally
uh
we would like to bring some
ahref
equal to
hash
that is the link which i need to provide
okay
so in this anchor tag we want to provide
a location called home here the first
list item which is there
like this i can provide some other list
items too
like i need to talk about call about
we're saying hash
about and here we say
about here
so this anchor tag is getting closed
okay
and
here before i close this list item here
you would like to take another url tag
okay in this ul tag we would like to
paste this list item again
and here with this hash we can just give
the name call
something whichever you want to give it
again
and
empty
so after that ul is also getting closed
li is also getting closed here
okay
after this we can provide few more li
tags here
okay so
href equal to here we would like to
provide a real url remove the hashtag
and say
https
simply learn
dot com
slash
corporate hyphen
training
okay and here we will be giving
the option called services
this falls into the category of what
services
like this we would like to provide one
more anchor tag for contact us
that's a
contact
one more for call our team
okay and here we save
our t
okay let me go back to my index.html
file
and check
illustrators
well it looks pretty nice now here we
have got simply learn solution with us
and right inside you can see now here in
about you see how the things are working
for me
this links are coming up automatically
it came because here if you remember
in my code
when i was saying this about
okay this was a part of our current code
and due to that it is now making it
possible for us
and that is possible because here in
whitestyle.css
if you remember
we were using this
a kind of
navbar uli
okay so the moment i try to hover
okay so this was giving me the complete
details and due to that
i was in position to get all the details
so let's pretty nice
okay so going forward what i would like
to do is within my program
as i could see in my index.html file we
have provided this
tag so ul is getting close this div is
getting close this tip is also getting
closed
okay
now here we would like to start another
table
we say dev class equal to banner image
minor underscore
image
okay
now within this tip i would like to use
one more div tag within this div we say
class equal to
banner underscore
content
okay
banner underscore content now within
this div class we would like to use this
h1
here we can say
welcome to
welcome to simply learn
okay after this
break tag as you know that is a for
break
and now
so this is pen tag we can say
words
okay
words
number one bootcamp
okay here the h1 tag is getting closed
after that the paragraph tag within this
paragraph we can say
get certified
get
ahead
this value
after this the div tag is getting closed
captioning not available
now
how my look and feel
is really gonna help because this banner
part i want to organize it because i do
not have a css for this
clear so certainly i need a css to
organize this particular banner
getting it because when you talk about
banner content so i need to tell where
it needs to go because i also would have
some banner image also too so i'll go
back to my css now
and in my style css
here
let me say banner content
banner underscore
content
and here we can save
text align
center and say color
we can say
white smoke
okay
and also within this banner content
we want to use the h1 tag
within this h1 tag you have to just say
text transform
uppercase
and line height
line height 30 pixels
okay and
margin bottom
this margin bottom we want to use 15
pixels
okay
so that's when we have it let me close
this
sorry
and here we want to use one more
property called banner content
with h1 and the span tag so that i can
change the color
so here
banner content
h1 we also want to use
span tag
within this i want to say
color
and you can just say
tomato and let's check does it affect my
application
yes exactly it does effect now you can
see it is somewhere coming down the line
like this
okay
so i can further change it
to my application like
if i talk about about and all so this i
can change it for sure because if i have
some images also
those images i also want to change
towards my application but it is just a
simple part
we are talking about call
banner part
and
we have also have to take some images
too
for this banner image
so let's go back
and talk about our index.html file and
see what some of the balance i want to
utilize it here
okay
now when we talk about get ahead i
certainly need some of the banner image
too but banner image is not available so
let me go back and try to use some
banner image whichever we have to define
under my
css
okay so here in my style css let me go
here and say
dot
banner underscore
image
in this banner image we have to say
background url
background
colon now you have to say url and in
this url we have to use this image
called images
slash p4
dot jpg
that will be my image and also we would
like to use one very common option that
is called no repeat
so that it should not repeat it and i
want to fix it to the top
and in the center
okay now let's check
perfect it is coming up but it is not
looking as good as it looks like it
so we want to use few more important
things saying this background size
background size cover
and also want to use width
width i want to use 100
and height
we want to use it called 600 percent
okay display
we want to use it flex
and justify content
we want to use it call center
and align items
center let's check this out
okay now you can see it looks pretty
better
compared to the previous version
whatever we have written it
but this image needs to be look even
more better
okay and the content needs to be more
awesome
but anyways that is the first thing
which we have written after that we have
to write an about us and other areas but
that is initially which i would like to
make it
even more better and more look okay
okay so we have seen the value still
call option called get certified get
ahead the div tag is getting closed and
i want to use another
div
and inside this div we want to say
class equal to about
okay and
id equal to about okay
and uh within this div tag i want to use
this h1 tag
with the attachment tag i say
class equal to
title
okay here i want to say
about us
actual time is closed after that i want
to define this paragraph and want to
give some details about a simple learn
okay like
and talk about simply learn
words number one
training okay we can just
provide
you know some details training providers
that's it so
we can write it that much about in
paragraph tag
and we can use this tab again
within this step we
say to
plus equal to
bdn
and say
a
hr f
equal to
and in the search results we would like
to say
colon
learn
dot com okay slash
resources and here we can just give the
option name phone
more
to this anchor tag the div tag is
getting close later on
okay and now
just like in dev we have provided here
we can also offer the details with
regards to your
services so i can just copy the same
and provide about the services so you
can say
services id equal to
services and you can provide anything
whichever you would like to provide
title is same about us we can say our
services
our services
so
you can give any details if you want
okay paragraph
now
here after this paragraph using div
class equal to
div
underscore
services
and uh
we may not have any hrf right over here
so we are removing this href tag
okay dev class equal to
diff on sickness very long
d i
developed inter services
here we want to use another div tag
and uh in this div tag we want to say
class
equal to
enter underscore
services
underscore
item
we have to basically provide
and within this i have to use this
option called img
src equal to now you have to provide a
location so i'm saying
under this images folder we have a call
services
because the results 1
dot jpg
alt equal to
in case of the service is not available
you can just say
service underscore image
okay within this
once this is close you like to use a h3
diagonal
and in this h3 tag i just say
class
equal to
sub
underscore
title and here we get the title name
called
web development let me go back and check
yeah so i can see this option called
about us is coming up
learn more if i talk about learn more
you see i'm taking you to the
website of this
simply done resources which are
available to us so this link is working
perfectly fine
and
i can see here called our services
it is the same
well going back so we have a call
this our services
so alt equal to
services underscore image sc class equal
to subtitle web development
and uh
that's it
so the div tag is getting closed here
and i may choose to
talk towards
diff service item so let me have
another div tag here
and
in this div tag we say
class equal to
dev
underscore
services underscore item
active underscore services underscore
item
okay now within this dev tag
okay
so
what do you want to offer now
i want to offer some again certain
images
so what those images will be let me try
to copy this
and the s3 tag to let me copy this again
service one i'm giving call service to
service underscore images so underscore
title rather than using web development
we can say app development
okay
so this div tag i will copy it again
which is getting closed and try to use
one more
so deep underscore service underscore
item okay images i'll say
service 3 instead service image and here
i can say online certification
online certification
okay so
like this
all the three dip tags are getting close
now and after that we will start
meanwhile let me check
so these image sizes are pretty big so i
just want to make them small
but initially they are okay
okay you can see we have called our
services
okay
so you can see like web development
so ema sizes are pretty big which we can
make them small
to cover up the way they are supposed to
but this way we'll be doing it little
later on
let's go ahead and talk about the
complete html portion which we want to
complete it now
okay so that online certification we
have taken
so also the three div tags are getting
closed now here onwards
we want to start the another table
okay with this dip we want to say class
equal to
equal to we want to use contactors
we want to say contact us and here
id equal to
contact us
let me try to wrap it with this single
quotes
okay and here we use this h1 tag
within this h1 tag we say
class equal to
title here
and
here i say contact us
contact us okay that is for the first h1
tag we are using it now
after that let's start with another div
tag
with this div we want to use class
equal to
form
underscore
wrapper
okay deb class equal to what form
underscore what wrapper
div
again
okay
class equal to
form underscore what input
and here we say
the input tag
so it is input applicable to what a
checkbox for me
so i would like to say
text instead input applicable to what
text and uh
just say remove the name and id and say
placeholder equal to
email
okay so this div tag is getting closed
after that i can also use
so for
i would say subject as well as for
message i copy this
form input
so once again
placeholder
subject
and
once again placeholder equal to what
[Music]
the options we are using it right now
okay
after this
once it is over we would like to use
another div
tag window
class equal to
btn
and within this i want to use
some anchor tag
a h f equal to hash
is equal to want hash
and want to use submit
okay that's it
now
[Music]
now you can see we have got these three
properties are coming up at the end
but certainly we can go back and try to
fix those images
which are there behind the scene
okay using what the style
so
first important thing is
we have got these images with us
what those images are if we just check
here we have a call
def service item
okay we have a call what dev service
item so that we want to change it but
before that i will go back to my style
and after this h1 span we want to use
for dot
about
okay dot
service we press enter
service
or i can say services
here we talk about dot
contact us
we also talk about dot dot
our team
okay
so these four properties we are trying
to use it by saying
texture line
center and
[Music]
adding five percent
ten percent
okay
now
we talk about services so we saying dot
services
with the services we can say
background
white
smoke
now we would like to provide the tip
services where we have these options
with us we say dot
div underscore
services
here
margin top
25 pixels
from margin top usa after that display
we are selecting this call type selects
also justify contents
of type space between
for dev services
now in this div services we may get many
different type of options
okay
this is the first dev service now in the
same option in part
tip services
space
we talk about dev services underscore
item
okay
and here we want to save it
thirty percent
okay now
i copy the same
in this div services item
so we want to use
image part that is the most important
area
here we say
width
hundred percent
okay and margin button
okay margin bottom 25 pixels
okay
okay now you can see this images looks
pretty nice
yeah looks better
so that's how you see your websites are
really creating some difference compared
to the previous one now they're aligned
properly and
you can see here
these images are really nice
okay that's the benefit so we have this
technique called decreases
and uh once this image part is closed we
would like to talk about h3 part
let me copy this
item
and with this item we say
three
in this h3 will say color
tomato and margin bottom
this are 15 pixels
okay for this h3
and when it comes to this text boxes
certainly you can change the look and
feel how you really want it
so for this you can say dot
form
underscore
wrapper
home underscore
input
okay formula perform input
we say
margin hyphen bottom
15 pixels
okay perform input
now in a similar line
uh form input we may have a hot text
area
input
text area and in this text area we
want to offer some of the details like
i'm talking about like in width we talk
about padding
let's talk about like in the width
i'm saying 250 pixels
okay we said padding
we say 12 pixels
and
20 pixels
we talk about
height
80 pixels we talk about resize
we talk about
none
we say border
this bottle we say one pixels
call it
and
right
this is for this
and in a similar one i can use it for
the text box so form colon input
whatever we have used it
form wrapper
form input so let me copy this
okay form input and here we say input
equal to
type of text
so what
combination you'll be using so i'll be
using width padding and border
copy
removing it
and
awesome
so they look
pretty nice
okay so we have this three text boxes
with us
and all are looking
nice the way
we are expecting from our application
okay so that's the one
which my application is offering about
this text area and all
so that looks really nice the way we are
expecting right now
okay
so
what are the areas we have seen
tiff services
item
and everything whichever you are saying
like this
so let's go back and check
to my index.html file
so we have a call
form wrapper which is the outermost
okay
you see now here it contains lot many
things
so here in my
program when i see like form wrapper
okay
form underscore wrapper
dot form input
and uh
talk about like the other details
talk about input type equal to text
you see like the border is like that
so if you want to have this border some
different color
and certainly use black
now you can see it looks pretty nice
because earlier it was looking like
pretty much different now at least i can
see
here the location has been given
okay uh so going back towards the
previous
html page so we had a call a submit
button with us
okay after this the
all three div tags are getting closed
and now onwards we would like to start
working with team details
so we are saying div
so div
class equal to
our team and uh
id equal to
team again
okay and now we want to use this h1 tag
here this h1 tag we say class
class equal to title
and here i say
13
in a h1 tag
now once it is over we will use again
another div tag
which having
class equal to our team wrapper
our
team underscore
wrapper
now within this step tag
uh we want to use one more div tag
here in this
class equal to
team underscore or team iphone one
base
t
there is a div tag now here we will be
using a lot of other div tags inside
this like
i say
div
class equal to team members
team members
okay
and uh
data hyphen
name equal to you can give any name like
let's give the name call
it's like space k
okay
and within this
i want to use one image tag
img space src equal to
images slash
team one
dot jpg
okay
so that's the first thing
we have it so this div tag is closed now
i copy the same
the total i want to use this three one
two
three
and here team members i would like to
change the name here
rather than display let me give the name
called
abiji and
one more
that it's gone
okay and change the name to to
4.53
okay so this is the first div we have
used it so this dream tag is getting
closed right over here
along with this the second drive tag is
getting closed
so
after having this
two div tags closed we want to use
another one so for team two
okay so i just copy the same
okay uh
i would like to go ahead with
team two team so team members
and
here i would like to say four five
four
five
six
and change the name
like
you can give anything i just give the
name called
suppose
rn
radash
and
so these names we are using it now let's
go back and see how it really looks
so these images are coming like that
okay so we want to use those images in
[Music]
somewhere not like this
or horizontal vertical so this spot fix
that issue i have to once again look
back to it to my styles
okay where
this option can be used in better way
i like to go back to my style.css
and want to use
the first option called dot over three
background
sorry
background now here we say
quite small car
now
again
poverty
wrapper
so in this i would like to say display
flex
and flex direction
space between
oh sorry column
let's check how it really looks like it
this is no more change
but
certainly few more classes can really
make a difference
so our team
okay underscore rapper
let's check this is the same name we
have used it
is our team
now in the same way we want to use this
team
so
again our team rapper
okay
dot
team
display
click
and justify contents
space between
okay
now here
we talk about t
we also want to say uh
our team underscore rapper
dot
team underscore
members
here we would like to give width
how much 30
and height
this will be auto
and here we'll be having cursor
pointer for sure
and overflow
hidden
and position
relative
this is for team members
now you can see it looks better now now
we have to basically divide those
because we have got separate team
members are available so we have to also
divide them too so here after this we
want to say
dot
our team
wrapper and again dot
team members
space img
these images we say
display
block
width
100
okay
height
auto
okay
transition
transition
or
transition i can say or type all
like this
okay and in a similar way
copy this team
and we'll say
members
over
image
and we can say
transform
scale
1.1
that's it
okay so we have this
look and feel appeared
okay with
transition image over so they're all
ready with us
okay everybody so after writing all
those the only difference i've made it
like i had used hyphen but i'm using
underscore here
finally when i see my look and feel
of this
i can see now it is moving you can see
now it is all moving okay so that gives
me the confidence of like yes exactly
the code is working the way it was
expected earlier
in my index.html file
okay so once this portion is over
okay we want to go ahead so three tip
tags are getting close one two and three
and here
we would like to start working with a
footer so here we start
further
so within this footer i say
class equal to
button
okay now after this i use container
there
okay
div class equal to what
container
and again
div
equal to
row
okay
now
do class equal to row again another div
equal to
footer hyphen col
call footer hyphen column now let me use
h4
within this h4 i say
company
okay
after this we want to use this ul
within this um
once again
i want to use some
link items
list items within this list item
a
equal to
so this hrf tag we want to say
hdb okay we have already used this
simplyrun.com url
here
let me copy this
come down
http.com rather than resources i can say
about us
about hyphen us
and here we say about this
it is getting closed
so
i copy this line again
okay
so
one more thing i want to use it think
href equal to
hash
and here we will say
our team
okay
after that
we want to offer the careers to be safe
we want to use
careers
here
review
concept
aluminum speak
so this is the detail of this so the ul
tag is getting close
and
after this evil tag is getting closed
uh
we want to use one more div class equal
to footer hyphen column
okay i copy this
it is getting closed here
okay so do classical to photo hyphen
column so rather than using company we
want to use test cover
discover
and here in this discover we say
simplylink.com
and here we have this option called
skillup
hyphen
free iphone
online hyphen
okay so here we will give the name call
scale up
okay
after this
we have this called careers we say
resources
very much
resources
here we can give the name call resources
again
resources
we have called tutorials
tutorials
reset
tutorials here
so like this we can create as my number
of urls as i want
okay
so
once it is over
let me copy this again
and here
photocolumn we say followers
follow
us
or else we can say this option name
called work with us
work
with us
in this work with us
we can have
some options with us and you will
remove those two
in this we would like to say guest
blogging
we say
guest
blogging
yes blogging we can say blog is guessed
blog
guest
another link which i have it here that
is called become our trainer
here we say
become
hyphen our iphone
trainer and we say
become an instructor
okay
so like that you're offering it and
once it is done
i can copy it once again this
there
and
provide few more
photo hyphen column
followers
okay
and
[Music]
follow us we would like to use another
table
okay we say
class
equal to
social hyphen
links
and this dev time will be closed later
okay
templars equal to social links
in this i can have some facebook.com
and uh
you know twitter.com and many more
names i can take it so here in our
dev classically social link here i would
not be using any url here
i would not be using any ally here
okay so i'm closing this even in a live
closing this url i to
well simplyname.com or else we can just
give the name called twitter.com
okay
twitter.com
okay
so
we can offer the user
to
follow us on a
instagram also or to the
twitter also so here we say
a hdf
but what we need to give it so we can
create.com
slash simply learn
we remove this values whichever we have
it
so instead we use this i
okay and in this i i say
equal to
okay anchor tag is closed
so in case if you want to talk about
like in
typical uh
[Music]
you know instagram that instagram also
you can use it now so here
we say http www
dot install
we say instagram.com
okay slash
simply learn underscore
underscore e-learning
okay and i want to use the same option
there also
i and with this
remove this
okay
so here just give the name called fa
hybrid
instructor
let's go back and check
okay so you can see now we have got this
links coming up for facebook as well as
what of this instagram so that looks
really nice that gives us a feeling of
yes
exactly the code the way we are looking
forward for it is working
the way it was expected
okay
and
if you want to offer
any
other type of details that also you can
offer but this is the first thing which
we have taken so this is the navigation
links are available
these navigation links
you could also change the way they
always look forward for so i'll be
providing some links which we can later
on use it
okay everyone so finally we are all
ready so i have basically added some of
the additional styles to my code you can
see here from
this one downwards we've added this
image url
this is for body this is for star
container row ul
this is for footer
this is for photo column so because we
are also using some photo portions into
my code as you can see we will call
photo column and photo class equal to
what
footer so implemented this photo
background color equal to black we have
used it padding 70 pixels footer column
further column because we are using this
h4 tag also you remember like we're
using this h4 tag also
so for all h4 tags this would be the
basic setting
for footer column h4 before we would
like to give the contents like this by
giving this background color height box
sizing width and then all
for the column un ali not last time
we're gonna give this margin bottom and
this is the style for photocolumn uli
and list
items clear and here we can see this
font size we are giving it this is for
over this is for photo column where we
have our social links whichever we have
created so it is showing me that this
plane line block margin border radius
and this is for social links when i try
to click on or over it so the color will
change to this white color
and the media this is for responsiveness
to make sure like in case if i reduce
the size of my browser they look
better the way it is expected
so when the line size will change to 720
pixels so this color will be changed and
this is the styles for arrow footer one
these all we have implemented
and finally my application when i
refresh it actually looks like that see
now this is the photo area of my
application
so i'm sure that this looks even more
better and convenient because when i try
to reduce the size
you see now it's still gonna give you
the responsiveness
can you see this now this is gonna give
you the responsiveness reason because
here we are using this
logic for
media when the change
of width will to 720 pixels if it is
going to 767 pixels so like that you
implement that so guys our project is
now ready i'm sure that you enjoyed
thank you very much
for enjoying this project so final our
application is set and our application
is working the way it is supposed to
work for us html stands for hypertext
markup language it is the most widely
used language for developing web
applications it was created by
berners-lee in the year 1991 but it was
published in the year 1995. html4 was a
popular breakthrough version and got
published in the year 1991.
this version gained a lot of popularity
and was adopted all over the globe for
developing web applications so without
further ado let's get started with the
interview questions based on html it's
the first question
what is html html stands for hypertext
markup language and it is the language
of the internet it is a standard text
formatting language used for creating
and displaying pages on internet html
documents are made up of the elements
and tags that format it properly and
display it on pages
so we have our next question now
what are html tags
so the answer for this question is html
tags are used for placing the elements
in a proper and appropriate format tags
use the symbols greater than and less
than to set them apart from the html
content
the html tags need not to be closed
always for example in case of images the
closing tags are not required for an
image tag
now followed by the second question we
have our third question what are html
attributes the attributes are the
properties that can be added to an html
tag that change the way the tag behaves
or displayed for example an image tag
an image stack has src attribute with
which you can use the source from which
you have to display the image from
now the attributes are added right after
the name of the html tag inside the
brackets the attributes can only be
added to opening or self-closing tags
but never in closing tags
now followed by third question we have
our next question what is mark you in
html mark you is used for scrolling text
on a web page it scrolls the image or
text up down left or right automatically
to apply for a marquee you have to use
marquee tags
now we have our fifth question how do
you separate a section of text in html
we separate a section of text in html
using the below tags which are the break
tag paragraph tag and block code the
break tag is used to separate a line of
text it breaks the current line and
shifts the flow of the text line to a
new line followed by that we have the
paragraph line the paragraph line is
used to write a paragraph of text and
third one the blog code the blog code
tag is used to define large quoted
sections
now we have our sixth question define
the types of lists in html so we have
the three types of lists in html which
are the ordered list unordered list and
definition list so first we'll discuss
the ordered list the ordered list uses o
l tag and displace elements in a
numbered format next we have the
unordered list the unordered list uses
ul tag and displace elements in a
bulleted format thirdly we have the
definition list the definition list uses
dl dt and dd tags and displays elements
in the form of definition
like a dictionary
next we have our seventh question
how do you align list of elements in an
html file we can align the list elements
in an html file by using indents if you
indent each nested list and further than
the parent list then you can easily
align and determine the various lists
and the elements that it contains
now we have our eighth question
differentiate between ordered list and
unordered list so the answer for this
question is an unordered list uses ul
tags and each element of the list is
written between li tags the items are
displayed as bullets rather than numbers
now coming into ordered list so for
creating an ordered list you will be
using ol tags and each element inside
the list is written using li tags the
list items are displayed using numbers
rather than bullet points now we have a
sample on the screen right now so the
first three elements are
a
set of unordered lists which are
represented using bullet packs and the
second set which is the coffee tea and
milk is an ordered list which is
represented using numbers
now moving ahead we have the ninth
question
how do you display a table in html web
page so the table and html can be
created or displayed using the table tag
so it also uses to manage the layout of
the page for example header section
navigation bar body content photo
section etc etc so given below are a
list of html tags used for displaying
table in an html webpage so we have
table tr th etc etc table is used to
define a table tr is used to define a
row in a table th for header td for a
cell caption is used to define a caption
and we have the call group which is used
to specify a group of one or more
columns in a table for formatting next
we have call which is used with call
group element to specify column
properties for each column next we have
t body which is used to group the body
content in a table next we have t head t
footer which are used for header content
and footer content respectively moving
forward we have our 10th question
how do you display the given table in an
html web page so the answer for this
question is written on the right side
part of my screen this is the sample
code which you can use to represent or
display a table which is given in this
particular format over here now followed
by this we have our 11th question how do
we insert a comment in html so the
answer for this question is
we can insert a comment in html by
beginning with lesser than sign and
ending with a greater than sign for
example as shown in the right side part
of my screen which is hello world now
moving ahead we have our 12th question
how do you insert a copyright symbol in
html so you can insert a copyright
symbol by using ampersand copy semicolon
or ampersand hashtag 169 semicolon in an
html file now moving ahead we have our
13th question so what is a white space
in html so the answer for this question
is an empty sequence of space characters
is called as white space in html this
white space is considered as a single
space character in html white space
helps the browser to merge multiple
spaces into one single space and so
taking care of indentation becomes
easier
white space helps in better organizing
the content and tags making them
readable and easy to understand
with this let's move into the 14th
question
how do you create links in different
sections within the same html webpage so
the answer is anchor tags we can use
anchor tag along with referencing
through the use of hashtag symbol to
create several links to different
sections within the same web page moving
ahead we have the 15th question how do
you create a hyperlink in html so the
answer is we can use anchor tag again
here the same thing we can use anchor
tag to create a hyperlink within the
html that links to another web page the
hyperlink can be added to images too now
moving ahead into our 16th question
define an image map so the answer for
this question is an image map in html
helps in linking with the different
kinds of web pages using this single
image
it can be used for defining spaces in
the images that are made part of the
image mapping process
moving ahead we have our 17th question
why do we use stylesheet in html a style
sheet helps in creating a well-defined
template for html web page that is both
consistent as well as portable a single
style sheet template can be linked to
various web pages which makes it easier
to maintain and change the look of the
website now the 18th question
what is semantic in html
so the answer for this question is
semantic html is a coding style it is
the use of html markup to reinforce the
semantics or the meaning of the content
for example the semantic html b tag is
not used for bold statement as well as i
tag which is not used for italic instead
we use strong and em tags
now followed by the 18 question we have
our 19th question
what is svg in html so the html svg is
used to describe the vector or raster
graphics svg images and their behaviors
are defined in xml text sheets it is
mostly used for vector type diagrams
like pie charts two dimensional graphs
in an x y coordinate system now moving
ahead we have our 20th question
what would happen if there is no text
between the html tags so the answer for
this question is really simple there
would be nothing to format if there is
no text present in between the tags
therefore nothing will appear on the
screen some tags such as the tags
without closing tag like image tag do
not require any text between them
now followed by the 20th question we
have our next question how do you create
nested web pages in an html so nested
web pages basically mean a web page
within a web page we can create nested
web pages in html using the built-in
iframe tag the html live frame tag
defines an inline frame for example
which is displayed on the right side
part of my screen you can see the iframe
source
which redirects the user to simply
learn's official web page
now followed by that we have our 22nd
question how do you add buttons in html
so we can use the built-in button tag in
html to add buttons to the html web page
so on the right hand part of my screen
you can see the implementation of button
to an html web page now followed by 20
second question we have our 23rd
question
what are the different types of headings
in html so the answer for this question
is there are basically six types of
heading tags in html which are defined
with h1 to h6 stacks
each type of the heading tag displays
different text size from another
where h1 is being the largest and h6 is
being the smallest so on the right hand
part of my screen you can see the
implementation of heading tags from h1
to h6 now the
output for this particular code segment
is the h1 h2 s3 h4 h5 h6 so you can see
that h1 is being the biggest one and h6
is being the smallest one now moving
ahead into our 24th question how do you
insert an image in the html web page so
the answer for this question is you can
insert an image in the html webpage by
using the following code which is
displayed on the right side part of my
screen you can see we have a image
source is equals to tulip.jpeg
which is used for inserting an image
into your html webpage
now our 25th question what is the alt
attribute in html now the answer for
this question is the alt attribute is
used for displaying the text in place of
an image whenever the image cannot be
loaded due to any technical issue
so basically when you have poor internet
connection and you're trying to load an
image you can see some sort of text in
place of an image so that particular
text is nothing but the art attribute
now moving ahead we have our 26th
question how are hyperlinks inserted in
the html webpage you can insert a
hyperlink in the html webpage by using
the following code which is present on
the right side part of my screen
you can use the anchor tag along with h
reference and inside that particular tag
you can use the url to which you want
your users to redirect to
now followed by this we have our 27th
question how do you add color to the
text in html
so the answer for this question is you
can add color to the text by using the
following code which is present on the
right side part of my screen where you
can add a red color and blue color green
color to this particular paragraph and
headings now followed by 27th question
we have our 28th question
how do you add css styling in html so
there are three particular ways to add
css to your html there are inline css
external style sheet and internal style
sheet we'll discuss each of these
methods in a bit more detail first we
have the inline css
so it is used when less amount of
styling is needed or in cases where only
a single element has to be styled to use
inline styles add the style attribute in
the relevant tag now moving ahead we
have the external style sheet this is
used when the style is applied to many
elements or html pages each page must
link to the style sheet using the link
tag
now we have the last one which is the
internal style sheet it is used when a
single html document has a unique style
and several elements need to be styled
to follow the format
internal style sheet is added in the
head section of the html page by style
tag now followed by this we have our
29th question
what hierarchy do the style sheets
follow
the answer for this question is if a
single selector includes three different
style definitions the definition that is
closest to the actual tag takes
precedence inline style takes priority
over embedded style sheets which takes
priority over external style sheets now
our last question for the session today
how do you add javascript to an html web
page so the answer for this question is
we basically have three methods to add a
javascript to our html webpage they are
inline script block and
external javascript file first we'll
discuss the inline
you can add javascript to your html
elements directly whenever a certain
event occurs javascript code can be
added using attributes of the html tags
that support it now the next one that is
the script block you can define a script
block anywhere inside the html code
which will get executed as soon as the
browser reaches to that part of the
document this is why script blocks are
usually added at the end part of the
html documents now the last one that is
the external javascript file you can
also add or import the javascript code
from a separate file and keep your html
code clutter free this is especially
useful if there is a large amount of
scripting added to the html webpage so
this session will be about become a
front-end developer
so let us begin
we are going to discuss the things you
need to know to become a web developer
first we will start with basic skills
which every web developer must know
before moving into more advanced web
frameworks
then we will understand what react is
and why it is so popular after that we
will go through another web framework
called angular
then we will also get to know about a
comparatively new front-end framework
called vue in the end we will go through
the front-end developer salary trends
which will give you an insight of the
job market
so without further ado let's get started
first the basic skills
let us understand what basic skills are
required to become a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path
these are the common things every
programmer should know
the first one is the github
so git is a free open source version
control system that enables
collaborations in a particular project
it is designed to handle both small and
large scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the feature updates in the
product or an application
so followed by the github the next
important thing we have is the data
structures and algorithms a data
structure is the location used to store
and organize data
an algorithm is a collection of steps to
solve a particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
allow us to write efficient and fast
computer programs
so followed by data structures and
algorithms we have the text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice
visual studio code is the top choice for
most of the web developers and my
personal choice too because of the large
support of languages and of course the
speed
the text editor is where you write all
your code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
the command line is an important tool to
get familiar with
it is how you run your code after
writing it on a text editor
the better you are on the command line
the more efficient you will be as
developer
so followed by the command line we have
the http and https the http protocol is
the backbone of the internet
it handles requests and responses from a
web application it is mandatory for a
web developer to have good knowledge of
both http and https in order to build
fast and responsive web applications
now that we know what basic skills are
required to become a front-end developer
let's discuss about the most popular
front-end library that has to react
now what exactly react is
so react is a front-end javascript
library used for building beautiful user
interface components it is an open
source meaning it can be used in your
commercial projects without any
restrictions
it is also component based and these
components can be used again and again
promoting code
reusability
it is an mvc or model view controller
architecture
react is the v responsible for how the
application looks and feels for the end
user now why should you learn react
react has always been in high
performance as it uses virtual dom
rather in real dom
so basically dom stands for document
object model and is used by every
internet browser for rendering a web
page or an application
react can also be easily integrated with
other javascript frameworks like node.js
resulting in the development of a
completely
new web application including front end
and the back end
it is comparatively easy to maintain
large-scale applications written in
react because
it highly promotes code reusability and
code readability
so followed by react the next important
thing we have is the angular
we have an idea of what react is but it
is not the only framework used for
building user interfaces so now let us
know about angular
so now what exactly angular is
angular unlike react is a fully fledged
framework for web application
development which usually does not
require additional libraries for
implementing additional functionalities
like routing
it is also open source and backed by
google and as regularly updated
resulting in constantly improved
performance and addition of new features
in terms of performance it was begged to
be much slower than react but with the
recent versions performance seems to be
on par with react
now why should you learn angular
angular is one of the most stable
frameworks out there
it is also the most complete meaning you
don't have the need to integrate with
other frameworks since it's pretty much
includes everything for the web
development of a complete web
application
angular backed by google is safe choice
for using in long-term projects since it
is not going anywhere anytime soon
angular is obviously used by google for
its web applications and also used by
other large-scale companies creating a
lot of job opportunities
now followed by angular the next one we
have is the view
now that we know quite a bit about the
two popular front-end frameworks namely
react and angular let's now go ahead
into
view and learn a bit more about vue.js
library
now what exactly is view
view is a lightweight and open source
progressive javascript framework used
for developing interactive web user
interfaces
it is meant to be integrated with other
libraries to develop a complete web
application
like react vue.js is mainly focused on
the view part of the web application and
hence it's bit faster when compared to
angular which is a complete web
application solution
view.js is commonly referred to as view
and pronounced as vue.js or view is
rightly so
now why should you learn vue
any beginner web developer can easily
understand view and start building their
own web user interfaces
like react view also uses virtual dom
resulting in better performance and it
also uses the component-based code
design promoting core reusability and
code readability
vue.js has become popular in recent
times and many companies are starting to
use it owing to its lightweight
performance and easy integration with
other web libraries and frameworks
now with this let's move into the next
section where we will discuss about the
front-end developer salary trends
now that we know what skills we need to
become a front-end developer let's now
have a look into the salarians of a
front-end developer
front-end developers are always in high
demand since new web applications are
launched and managed continuously
there are generally offered generous
salaries across the globe
the salaries also depend on the factors
like frameworks skills and the work
experience
the average salary of a front-end
developer in india is 5 lakh 6 000
rupees per annum
the average salary of a front-end
developer in united states is 76
and
us dollars per annum this session will
be about web development roadmap in 2021
so let us begin
assuming that you know what web
development is the roadmap is divided
into three sections the first section is
all about the common skills which every
web developer should know while the
second and third are about front end and
the back end development the main areas
of web development
so you can either learn front end or
back end or both depending upon your
choice so if you want to become a full
stack web developer then you have to
learn both front end and the back end
there is no escaping there in the end we
will also go through the salaries of web
developer
so without further ado let's get started
the first one that is the common skills
let us understand the basic skills that
you require to become a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path these are
the common things every programmer
should know
the first one is git
get is a free and open source version
control system that enables
collaboration in a particular project it
is designed to handle both small and
large scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the future updates in a product
or application
the next one is the data structures and
algorithms a data structure is a
location used to store and organize data
an algorithm is a collection of steps to
solve a particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
will allow us to write efficient and
fast computer programs
followed by data structures we have the
text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice next visual studio is the
top choice of the most web developers
and my personal choice too because
it has a large support of languages and
of course the speed
next
text editor is where you write all your
code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
a command line is an important tool that
you need to get familiar with
it is how you run your code after
writing your code on the text editor
the better you are on the command line
the most efficient you will be as a
developer so followed by command line
interface you have the http or https
the http protocol is a backbone of the
internet it handles the requests and
responses of a web application
it is mandatory for a web developer to
have good knowledge of both http and
https in order to build a fast and
responsive web application
so followed by common skills we have the
front end developer
front end development is all about
developing the user interface and its
interaction with the client end
let's go ahead and look into this field
of web development
there are a few things that you must
know for becoming a front-end developer
let's discuss these things
so the first one is the web development
basics it is necessary to know the
basics of web before moving on to
programming languages
next you should know stuff like web
applications protocols like http and web
development in general so followed by
web development basics we have the html
and css
html and css are the backbones of any
website html provides the structure
while css provides the style to make
them visually appealing
mastering these two technologies is a
must to become a front-end developer
browser in the end renders html and css
on the web page regardless of the
technology used to develop that page
followed by html and css we have the
javascript javascript is an extremely
important technology that every web
developer should learn
most of the popular web frameworks like
react.js and node.js are built upon the
javascript
javascript makes the web applications a
love by adding interactivity and dynamic
updating of web applications followed by
javascript we have the typescript
typescript can be considered as an
extension of javascript angular uses
typescript as a space language
it adds type safety to javascript to
cache errors in the development phase it
also helps in developing object oriented
code for javascript so followed by
typescript we have the angular
angular is a web framework used to
create a single-phase applications
it is backed by google therefore
learning angular is a good choice for a
modern web developer
so followed by angular we have react js
react is a popular library for
developing fast and responsive web
applications
it is backed by facebook and quite
popular because of its simplicity and
performance it allows you to create a
reusable components that can be used to
create modern web applications
so followed by react.js we have view js
view is like other frontend frameworks
that is used for building user
interfaces
it is comparatively easier to integrate
view with other libraries or existing
projects
it is a newer framework but it has
really picked up speed last year and
being adopted more
now followed by the front-end developer
we have the back-end developers
so back-end development is more about
caring how application works and ensure
that it keeps running smoothly let's go
ahead and know more about this field of
web development
there are a few things that you must
learn for becoming a back-end developer
let us discuss those things
so the first one is the node.js node.js
is a javascript runtime built on
chrome's v8 javascript engine it allows
you to develop a complete web
application using javascript
it is best suited to be used for web
applications in conjunction with
javascript frameworks like react.js
so followed by node.js we have python
python is a popular language used in
various fields of tech applications
django is a backend framework based on
python used for server-side scripting it
is also known for its speed and
efficiency
python is also easy to get started with
programming language if this is your
first time coding followed by python we
have java
java has been the most used language for
a long time it is primarily used for
back-end development
you can either use core java or java
with spring boot for high performance
back-end
next we have
next we have ruby ruby is a dynamic
programming language that focuses mainly
on simplicity
it has a syntax that is very easy to
read and close to english language
phrases
the web framework ruby on rails is
popularly used for developing packing
systems so followed by ruby we have php
and mysql
php although treated as a hard to learn
language is still the easiest way to
write server-side code
at least 50 percent of the internet runs
on php and
mysql
mysql is the most popular database for
storing data of a web application
now followed by the backend developer we
will enter the next important stage of
web development roadmap in 2021 that is
about the web developers salary trends
let's now have a look on the salary
trends of a web developer web developers
are always in demand since new web
applications are launched and managed
continuously they are generally offered
generous salaries across the globe
salaries also depend on the types of web
developers for instance full-stack
developers are paid more than the
front-end and back-end developers
the average salary of a web developer in
india is 3 lakh 86 000 per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the united states is 68
524 u.s dollars per annum i'm sure
you've all heard the phrases software
development and web development
and i wouldn't be surprised if you use
them interchangeably or even mistook a
software developer for a web developer
well let me break your bubble
they are different
today's topic of discussion is software
developer versus web developer
so moving ahead who is a web developer
now a web developer builds and maintains
websites and other web applications he
takes web design and turns it into a
website
web developers are responsible for how a
website or web application looks and
functions from its user interface and
page layout to back-end systems for
gathering data
a web developer is expected to
collaborate with clients stakeholders
and organization leaders to design
unique and engaging websites for
businesses non-profits government
agencies and anyone else who is looking
to communicate more effectively online
so diving a bit deeper a web developer
can specialize in different areas based
on their skill
you have the front-end developers now
these are experts who are in charge of
how websites and applications look and
function from the user's perspective
next there are back-end developers who
focus on the technical aspects of
websites and web applications that
support both
basic and advanced functionality
now they largely work on administrative
components which include databases
website architecture application logic
creating new apis and user interfaces
based on predefined specifications
and lastly there are full stack
developers who are professionals
responsible for the development of an
application from start to finish
they specialize in both front end and
back end of the application development
typically a web developer should have
good skills in various frameworks and
markup languages like html css
javascript
react chairs angular and database
management systems like mongodb
and backend tools like node
so i hope this helped you understand who
a web developer is some of their
responsibilities and their basic skill
set
next up
let's understand who a software
developer is
now software developers are responsible
for creating more complex applications
and programs for computers and mobile
devices
they create conceptualize program
document test and upgrade software and
their components
software developers invent manage and
optimize computer programs that run on
desktops laptops smartphones and other
mobile devices
these computer science professionals
write complex code that governs how
desktop applications function
they also specialize in troubleshooting
code bugs
updating user interfaces creating new
tools and much more
just like web developers professionals
in this field are often categorized into
specific roles based on their
specializations
we have the application software
developer and the system software
developer
now an application software engineer is
a professional who focuses on designing
specific desktop and mobile applications
tools and games for consumer audiences
and a system software developer
is largely concerned with designing
systems level software for enterprise
customers rather than the public
the software they develop is used to
manage corporate network apps
database management systems and other
critical infrastructure
talking about their desirable skills
they need to be proficient in
programming in the field of javascript
java c-sharp php python and ruby they
must also have a good understanding of
operating systems network and database
management
so now moving on to the main topic of
discussion software developer versus web
developer
first let's compare the two based on
their prowess or area of expertise
a software developer is associated with
developing products that can be run on
multiple systems
this product could be any kind of
software
their area of work includes requirement
analysis planning
coding testing of applications
implementation deployment and
maintenance
talking about web developers they are
responsible for the development of
websites
they are also expected to follow the
process of the software development
lifecycle while building their products
next up is the type of product
now a software developer creates
programs for standalone desktop or
mobile platforms
on the other hand a web developer takes
care of the web framework server side
functions api integration and the
business logic
the third point of comparison is product
compatibility
now software development applications
are compatible across multiple operating
systems or platforms
the web applications on the other hand
are designed to be compatible across
multiple web browsers
next up is the learning curve
well software engineering never focuses
exclusively on coding
however you should know at least a
couple of languages and a deeper
understanding of how they function
some of the languages that you should be
proficient in include java c-sharp
python and some of its libraries and
frameworks javascript and ruby among
others
a web developer should be familiar with
markup languages like html css
javascript libraries and frameworks like
react and
angular he should also have a good hold
of back in frameworks like python django
and node
the next parameter is a job title
now there are different job titles for
these professions
some of them for software development
are software developer software engineer
junior software developer senior
software developer and a software
architect
on the other hand a web developer could
receive titles like front-end developer
back-end developer full-stack developer
or just a web developer
now of course companies have discretion
over assigning these job roles to their
employees
lastly let's look at the job outlook and
salaries
now the job growth projections for
software developers are even more
optimistic than those for web
development roles
alongside promising job growth software
developers also have higher salaries
than other it professionals
now the average salary of a software
developer in the us is around 76 000 us
dollars per annum and the average salary
of a software developer in india is
around 5 lakh indian rupees per annum
for a web developer the average salary
in the us is around 68 000 us dollars
per annum and in india it's around 4
lakh indian rupees per annum
now i'm sure you must be confused as to
which one to choose
well to be frank it's just a matter of
preference if you have strong knowledge
of data structures file systems
algorithms source control operating and
network systems then software
development would be a better choice
but if you have creative ideas for
websites love designing them have a good
understanding of html and css and
ultimately the knack to integrate your
design ideas to create responsive user
interfaces then a web development role
could be a good career path
then web development could be a better
career path to choose
today's topic is web developer versus a
web designer
now it is extremely common to get
confused between a web developer and a
web designer
now these roles are used interchangeably
given their names and dependency on each
other
however there are a few differences
among them
people aspiring to get into web
development often ask me
which role is suitable for them or
rather where do they fit in or what has
to be done during the process of web
development
so i've particularly kept this session
cleared to clarify all your doubts and
provide an insight into both web
developer and web designer roles and
their responsibilities
so let's begin
first let's look at what's in store for
us
we'll first look at what web development
is
then we'll understand who exactly is a
web developer
after that we will have a look at what
web designers actually do
moving ahead will compare between web
developers and designers to give you a
greater insight into both the roles
then we'll look at the current salary
trends of a web developer and a designer
in the tech industry
and lastly we'll conclude with deciding
which role to go for
so without further ado let's get started
what exactly is web development
so web development is the process of
building websites and applications for
the internet
now keep in mind that web development
and web design is seen as different
fields in most of the use cases even
though they collaborate together to
provide the end result that is the web
application
so the web development can be broken
down into three layers that is the
client-side coding which includes the
front-end then you have the server-side
coding which is the back-end and then
you have the database technologies
but who exactly is a web developer
now that we know what web development is
let's understand this
so here are some of the technologies
used by a web developer there's html for
web layout
css for web styling
javascript for making web applications
more responsive and interactive
there's react.js which is a javascript
framework used for front-end development
and then there's nodejs which is a
javascript framework again used for
server-side development
there's mongodb which is a database
technology for storing data for web
applications
and then there's also angular which is
another front-end development framework
based on typescript
now there are many other technologies
like php java ruby etc
and these are most commonly used by all
the web developers
but
you might be wondering who a web
developer is now the role of a web
developer is to build and maintain
websites
he also takes a web design which has
been created by either a client or a
design team and turns it into a website
now web developers are also responsible
for building a product that meets both
the clients needs and those of the
customers and the end users
web developers collaborate with
stakeholders clients and designers in
order to understand the vision
a web developer also has to perform
specific tasks
however these responsibilities may vary
depending on whether they're working as
a frontend backend or a full stack
developer
generally full stack developers
specialize in both the front end and the
back end
so let's go ahead and know more about
each type of web developer in this field
now there are basically three types of
web developers
there's a front-end developers
who build and maintain the client side
of an application
then you have the back-end developers
who work behind the scenes and manage
the services of a web application
and finally you have full stack
developers who manage the project
workflow and work on the required
features of a web application
now let's look at each role in detail
first up when it comes to front-end
developers they usually code the client
side of a web application
while the back-end developers build and
maintain the services needed by a web
application behind the scenes and then
you have the full stack developer whose
province is in both front-end and
back-end development
now front-end developers convert the
design into a real-life application
using html javascript and css
back-end developers on the other hand
ensure that the web applications keep
running smoothly
and full stack developers supervise the
development and guide on best practices
front-end developers ensure responsive
and adaptive user interface for your
applications
back-end developers manage services like
api data storage for the web application
and so on
and full-stack developers know both the
business requirements and the user
interface requirements
now let's go through the skill set of a
web developer the skills that a web
developer must have
are html that is the markup language for
building web page layouts
css which is the style sheet for styling
the html elements in a website
there's javascript which is a scripting
language for bringing web applications
to life by making them more interactive
and responsive
and he should also know front-end
frameworks like react angular view that
help in making the client side of
applications look better and speed up
the development
moving on you have the backend developer
skills
there's php which is the backend
language that helps in maintaining all
the work that happens behind the scenes
in a web application
and then there's python which is a very
popular language used in various
software development fields it is used
to handle server-side tasks in web
development then there's java which is
one of the most used languages for
software development and therefore is
also used in backend development by
developers
and then there's database management so
databases like mysql and mongodb are
used for storing data for web
applications
now full stack developers
have skills that cover both front end
and backend development of a web
application
therefore they manage the workflow of a
web application development environment
moving on who exactly is a web designer
now here are some of the technologies
used by a web designer
there's adobe photoshop for image
editing and web design
there's adobe illustrator for working
with vectors and scalable web elements
sketch for designing user experience for
web applications
adobe xd also used for user experience
design of web and mobile applications
adobe indesign for marketing campaigns
like banners posters and magazines
there are many other technologies like
adobe after effects blender that are
used by web designers as well
but you might be wondering who exactly
is a web designer
so web designer is one who plans and
designs the layout and other elements of
a website or an application
he performs digital retouching along
with image editing or video editing in
some cases
web designers are responsible for
designing a product that meets both the
clients needs and those of the customers
and end users
he also designs products that are user
friendly appealing and visually
effective
the design is preferably modern and also
easy to use at the same time
so let's go ahead and know more about
the design role
some of the popular design roles include
web designers who design websites and
its elements there is ux designers or
researchers who are responsible for the
user experience of a web or a mobile
application
there are multimedia specialists who
specialize in handling media for web
applications like images and videos
and then you have game designer which is
another role that employs similar tools
as that of web design like adobe
creative cloud
now let's look at each role in detail
a web designer designs the look of
websites and its elements a ux designer
designs and prototypes the look and feel
of web applications and mobile
applications
a multimedia specialist handles media
requirements like editing images videos
etc
then you have the game designer who
designs the props and characters of a
game for various platforms a web
designer typically uses tools like adobe
photoshop and adobe dreamweaver
a ux designer uses tools like adobe
illustrator sketch adobe xd
a multimedia specialist mainly uses
adobe creative cloud which includes
photoshop illustrator and after effects
and then the game designer uses tools
like adobe illustrator autodesk software
blender and unity
so let's go to the skill set of a web
designer
the skills that a web designer must have
adobe creative cloud this is the
industry standard software for web and
multimedia design a web designer must
have an imaginative mindset to design
modern web elements
a web designer must also be creative
enough to make the app look visually
appealing
he must also have the ability to give
attention to detail for minor features
and improvements in the web or mobile
applications
some of the other soft skills include
communication skills collaborative
mindset and patience
so now let's make a detailed comparison
between web developer and a web designer
so to summarize we've put together
a table for you
so a web developer
builds web applications using languages
like html css and javascript while a web
designer designs the web applications
using tools like adobe photoshop or
sketch
a web developer frequently uses
javascript frameworks for more
streamlined development
while a web designer uses adobe creative
cloud for most of the design needs
a web developer should possess good
coding skills while a web designer
should have good graphic design skills
web developers have to keep themselves
up to date with the latest web
frameworks and libraries
while web designers have to keep
themselves updated with the latest
design trends and color palettes
so going ahead let's look at the
industry trends
web developers usually have a trend of
earning more than the web designers
still it depends on how well you perform
in your particular job role
so if you're good in web design you
might actually earn more than a fellow
web developer
so the average salary of a web developer
in india is around 3 lakhs 90 000 rupees
per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the united states is around 68 000
dollars per annum
the average salary of a web designer in
india is around three lakh sixty
thousand rupees per annum
while the average salary of a web
designer in the united states is around
fifty three thousand us dollars per
annum so
moving to the most important question
which one should you choose
it is really a matter of preference
if you have a creative bent of mind and
enjoy using good looking web and mobile
applications and also enjoy designing
them then i would suggest you go for a
web or ux designer role if you have a
technical background like java or python
and you're interested in bringing the
designs to life i would suggest you go
for a web developer role so this brings
us to the end of this full course
i hope it was useful and interesting
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to the simply learn channel
thank you and keep learning
you